You
Hello
Wedding with ya. Hello. Hello. Hello. I have fear with me
I hide the baby girl
She hanging out
Oh
Big young look up here. He looks so funny
Poor pohia a
Poor pohia. Can I have a kiss? I want to kiss give me kiss. Yay kiss. Oh, no boomies here go away
You're ruining it. Oh my god, you're so heavy, dude
There's nothing over here for you. He kept trying to steal fias food when I was feeding fia on my desk
That's when he started when I didn't give him food he started screaming and getting really angry and running around
And then he just randomly tackled reina and reina was not having it. Oh
So you the tomagachi
I
Sorry, this is hard to line up focus
Look how ugly it is
Frick is that I don't know what that is
Whatever
And I dressed it up I try to make it look cuter
He's doing flips because he's happy because I fed him
He was just playing with fireworks inside the house
Let me uh, let me have him play with another toy. I'll have him play with a
With a stuffed animal boomy chill out, please
His food because I wanted to feed feed fias sooner rather than after because
This isn't my normal stream time and normally fia gets fed at nine and so does all the other cats their food goes off at specific times
And so you will hear a food dispenser your beloved at some point
And uh, he not ugly. Nah, he ugly bro. He ugly
Um, just like dad. Okay. Well, never mind if you'd say it looks like you then I don't want to
Um, let me make myself a little bit bigger
There we go
So this is wedding witch. I love this game
I haven't played it in a while. Um
Um
Since my pl so it's it's been a bit but I do like this game a lot
uh
I don't really know how to explain it's literally what is that it's like
It's like the hollow live game
Yeah, it's a survivor like
Um, I'll be honest with you
This is just a chill stream
We're just hanging out. Um
Um
It's somewhat difficult for me to like do chat interaction with this. I'll try my best
Sad father tipped four dollars and 20 cents. Please let our child live. I don't think my mental health can take another loss
He will live
Maybe here. Let me turn up that and let me turn down
I forgot you can't use mouse in this
If you do z
That's fine
Uh, because like I remember like the first times I've played this game
I was like, I did not know what the heck I was doing. Fia, are you
Where are you sleeping face down?
Hi, sorry, sorry to wake you ma'am. I'm just making sure you're not suffocating yourself
Huh, are you gonna sneeze?
Oh
Thank you cows for the the four dollar super appreciate it
Um, thank you sad father. That's that's
Fia, why are you face down?
Guys, she's she's just she's just sleeping. Okay, please don't think that my cat is dead
She's literally just sleeping. See sign of life
She's like stop making me up, please
I know oh kisses. You still have some food in your bed. Do you want that?
I want that food you missed
You get it
Please don't lick your bed. Okay
Yeah, she's eepy she even she'll probably turn into like a little like croissant soon enough
um, I actually like this angle for the camera because um
It's top down so you can kind of really just look at her except then from just the side
um
But yeah
I
I'm gonna make the time I got you do one more thing before I get started, but I hope you guys are doing well
I'm a little sleepy. I just woke up. Um, I woke up and then I was an emmy stream
I literally have been watching Azura's stream all day
Um, I fell asleep to her stream. I had her on the background and then I popped in to see emmy
Um
And then I popped in right in time so I could help her with the dress stuff
I still have to send her some like flat chested stuff
Although honestly, I'm probably gonna tell her that anything that zoomie to kumi puts on
um
Because she is flat
Because she uses the same outfits that I like the same person that I do they would probably definitely work for emmy
um
Let me see
You're already full. Sorry. I'm feeding the tomagotchi. That's why I'm looking down
Oh
Let's see. What should I have you do?
Look at look look what it does. So I got it a ball
I'll show you
I have to like headphones are getting caught under my boo
You
Just juke's everybody
And he scores a goal like my kids an athlete, right?
Wrong. It was all a dream
It was all just a dream
Is there a header goal? Yeah, so fast. I literally said in the discord when she was at like 8k
I'm like, wow at this rate. She'll probably get to 10k in like an hour and then 10 minutes later
She hit 10k and I was like never mind
Well, like it's so happy for her like there's so many goal like there's so many stretch goals
They don't even know
There's like I know the other stretch goals that um, there's more than what she's shown you guys
So, yeah, maybe some some some oilers will drop some big money so everybody can see what they are
I think
Um, scrawny just as a contingency went all the way up to 30k
Not that like of course we're so small. I don't know if that would happen, but like
Um, sorry, there's a fucking bug. I'm trying to clap out
But yeah, it's it has been really nice. It's been really nice stream. Um, hi, how's it going? Hello
How sound is it too loud or anything I can turn it down if you guys want
There's a slime girl up there. Yeah, I know
Yeah, there's definitely a slime girl up there
Hmm
Sounds perfect. Okay
Um, so if you don't know about this game, it's about a witch who's getting married and she is doing
She's trying to get flowers or I can't remember
Well, I'll I'll you'll you'll see
So there's different versions
Her name is bell
I wonder if she's related to to me. Is this is a chabelle?
Um, you have achievements. Oh this sucks because I have to do everything over again
Because I beat the I essentially beat the game last time. Um
So you got like upgrades all that jazz
I think this game came out like last year. Um, and then your story mode and then some unlockable
I
The game has plot
The hat must grow I was like I was debating whether or not to make it a meme every time I die that my hat gets bigger
The hat that I'm wearing, um, but yeah, you have different
Which of the yeah, you guys see you guys know you guys know what's up ready to do story mode. Um
You got normal winning hard winning nightmare wedding
Oi get up already. Oi. Oi homeland has got my son. How long do you intend to stay in bed?
Oh do I no wait no wait
I accidentally clicked space to skip
I
Sorry, oh, I get up already. How long do you intend to stay in bed? I accidentally skipped the plot
Uh
Just leave me alone because I'm not budging until the wedding ceremony
I'm not even going to eat anything the dress won't fit if I gain weight
Here we go again
Oh
Sorry
Oh each passing day makes me so nervous. I could just die
Even ordinary people get married. There's no need to raise such a fuss
Easy for you to say
So were you able to look into what I asked about earlier?
Who do you think I am there's nothing the world my eyes can't find
Uh you mean
That's right. I've just finished research in human weddings. So get up already
Yay, I'm up. I'm up
Now according to my research humans have several rituals they perform at wedding ceremonies
Like what?
First a bride appears in a wedding dress accompanied by beautiful music
Okay, and then
After saying some bridge gibberish or whatever the bride puts a ring or restraint on the groom in front of everyone
Chaining him to her for all eternity
Hello, hello, welcome in welcome in
Wait strontis here
Oh, wait, no, I just mean I'm like strontis should be asleep
Oh
Lastly the bride extorts gifts from the guests as they congratulate her
I don't know. I saw it in astralia and no
How wonderful I love weddings
And after the ceremony the first night with the groom begins
For first night
What what's that? I don't know anything about it
Don't pretend you don't know you've seen how familiar is the bread your fucking twat
How dare of you speak of such things in front of a lady. I'll shove it your fucking cunts
Oh
Please don't give me that look that says you've come up with an idea. Who makes me nervous?
I swear it's a great idea. I just need your help
This'll make the best first night. I mean
The best wedding ever
Oh
You what are you thinking of bringing us to this forest?
You should know that this is the succubus's queen's domain
Exactly. Now you can guess what I'm about to do. Can't you?
No, I cannot
You know the potions that the old lady drinks before she seduces a man
It makes one very alluring
The alluring indeed
Yeah, that grandma has them hidden around this forest. I just have to find them
Then once I have them, I'm sure my darling will
You know this forest is amazed. Did you bring me so yep, you're going to be my wing man
I could get lost because the roads keep changing here. So please help me find the potions
All right, I should pick some flowers for the bouquet too
And while we're at it, let's go and extort some gifts from the devils
Uh
I don't think this is how it works
Okay, so you got onslaught um
onslaught time attack
Or that so you have so essentially you have milk, which is the big titty potion
You have cat girl potion or you have strong lady potion. I will let you guys decide
The chat on stream isn't working. Thank you for telling me
If it's if it continues to not work, I'm probably just gonna get rid of it because it just always does that
Live
Muscle milk strong strong. I'm seeing a lot of strong. Can't we do a poll? Oh, yeah facts
Potion seller I am going into battle and I need your strongest potions
I realize I feel I like I should be doing polls more often for the lurkers
So
My potions are too strong for you chat
They would put down a beast let alone a man they put down a werewolf
This is the hardest decision of my life
And I'll try to be consistent with it
Oh, there's no potions after that really because it's on baby mode
All right, looks like milk is winning by a landslide can I freaking I'm hitting shift instead of the window key to tab out
Mommy
Hi nori
Hi my sweet girl
Damn strong only got 27 percent everybody wants milk. All right, we'll do it. I have to remember how to freaking play
So I literally just stand here and I get
I'll get like stuff
You know just like some survivor game I don't want to oh and then there's a bonus and I'm very slow. Wow. I'm not used to this
So, uh
This is interesting so I'll get like bonuses and stuff and so it's really dependent on
What am I
Going to try to build around because I have milk. I honestly forget what the
um
The power milk has I can't I don't think it's like area damage. I can't recall if it is or not
Then there's explosives and there's doubt dodgery. Um
Yeah, no, it's yeah, it is legit holo cure
I should play holo cure. I've never played holo cure
Yeah, the flowers put they stay on until I die just freaking fruit fly. Where did you come from?
Did I kill you? I don't even know just flew in front of my screen. Uh, I'm gonna do
I'm gonna do the critical hit
And then as I continue to kill people I'll be able to get more
Oh, I'm gonna get fucking ganked in here. Hold on
Okay, so now oh, it's curses. That's what it is. Well, that's that's the succubus one so I can get
Holo cure is legit a great game if you don't care about the holo life stuff
Oh, no, I don't know why I haven't played holo cure yet
Yeah, okay, so maybe I'll I'll do holo cure at some point
I
Already have my schedule for next week or I would put it up. We're doing all FPS is next week
Um, I don't really care about
that
It's not that good. I'm gonna do my critical rate up because I literally just
Set wanted to get area damage with critical so we'll do that
And then you got like little pumpkins
Oh fuck. Uh, oh fuck. Uh, I forget I can dodge
And usually I will get
Like my absorption rate up
Uh, so I don't have to be so close
But yeah, they get to me little powers. Oh, it could be this
Tealth
Give me those coins baby girl. I don't really need this but yeah
I like the noises that they make when you smack them
smack my bitch, uh, okay, so I get it. I like I honestly like the area area, uh attacks because, um
Um
It kind of just helps me back up and I can only always swing back around
Oh god, oh fuck. Oh shit. Oh fuck. Uh, let's do absorption rate
Because that means that I don't have to get too close
Yeah, I didn't do that. Oh health perfect
And I think area is really good for a first run. Oh fuck me bro
Being ganged up on
I'm accidentally walking into stuff. Um, I get the power up
Again, you could see like when I'm in early stages of the game
It's hard for me to look at chat because I'm just trying to freaking dodge
Let's go over here. Let me look at you guys
Yeah, milk, but yeah, it's milk that boost area
Oh frick bro, please let me live my life
I literally just have to kill enough people I think I don't know
Uh, let's do attack angle
What that's what you guys this is you guys chasing me for after our wedding
Wow
Honestly, I'm not getting the best drops. Oh, let's do
Let's see
Step on them. I'm a gamer. I'm a real gamer. So I'm gonna do oh no milk is the uh
Milk is the the big breasts uh
Hips is area because I've been focusing on area. I'm going to continue with area
I'm so sorry
Oh
Wedding which trying to make a wedding bunny. Oh
Yeah, you're good. Don't worry about it. Um, so this is another onslaught which is annoying
Oh
What the hell is that noise?
I don't like that
I don't recognize these enemies to be honest with you. These are new. I wonder if they updated the game recently
Oh, fuck me. Why are you so fast for no reason?
I'm getting ganged up on help help
I need more
Like I'm gonna be dying a lot
in this first bit because
Oh, Jesus. Oh, Jesus. Oh
Jesus christ
Please please where's where's the space? Oh god. Oh shit. Fuck
I don't have a lot of like, um power ups
Oh
Okay, I gotta go up here to chase the flower
Look at chat. How does healing work? Uh, I literally have to pick up healing
Oh my god, what the frick
Why is this so hard for no reason? I can't even get towards the flower
Brother brother, I may die. Um
Let's see
I'm at absorption. I'm too I'm too close to everything. Jesus
Oh my god, please I'm gonna die. Oh my god, give me this
I can't even
I'm trying to get to the damn flower. That's all I care about
Oh, damn those could have had health. I'm probably gonna die. Uh, okay
Honestly, because for the first time that was a bad run because I was getting nothing
Yeah, it's fia
Oh
She likes giving kisses
Make the hat bigger. Oh, we're doing that. All right, I'll make the I'll make the hat bigger
Hat has gotten bigger
It's gonna take up wow wow ye of bigger of bigger faith of little faith. Okay, so now that
So now I have achievements
And I can claim that
I don't have any more though. Um, so I can go to upgrades and I can upgrade stuff
So
So I got not I have 342. Welcome. Welcome to harem emotes. Um
I can do attack power. I prefer speed speed is important to me because then I could run away because I suck
So, yeah, you can already see movement speeds pretty high. Uh, I'm gonna do
Item absorption
I'm gonna do attack speed
And
We'll do that. Okay, we don't have to view the story
Is there a bigger hat upgrade there there is not okay, so you got cat girl love potion or hips potion
Or uh succubus potion
Which one would you prefer which path?
Which way western man
Well, actually, you know what I'll do I'll let you guys pick. Um, what?
Uh potions I choose just for some fun stuff
So like at the end of a level when I move up you guys can pick the potion that I choose
Um
Well, they're all technically succubus potions, but that's the more succubus potion
Hips is pretty hot
Oh, let me tell you a secret. Um at the end the if I fill up all the hearts with a specific potion
Then I unlock a new form as you guys saw on the splash screen. Yay. V sucky
All right, it's gonna close at 8 34
I never tweeted I was live hold on let me do that while you guys figure that out
My allergies have been fricking killing me
What the
scrawny's picture
in me ooing
And then is there a drew scrawny? I mean scrawny drew is there a stepping on somebody? That's funny. Um
Let me cut away
Hips one all right, let me we are hip maxing
Forgot to say I was live
Hey
He he who who would you like a poo poo? I'm kidding. Let me retweet this on my own
What if I just secretly switched my accounts
for my alt to my main and my a main to my alt and I don't mean like just
Switching it like oh making my alt now my main no
I mean like changing everything like changing the name and so making everybody
And I would
I'm kidding. I'm not gonna do that
Because then people will look at my past tweets when they're looking for professional stuff and they're like, what is this?
Do it for April no no no no I gotta think of something for April first
Okay, this is a time attack. So I just have to live. Oh my god, reina. No not the time
It's a time attack. I can't do this reina. I'm so sorry
You
To me I made my mistakes
Hey
Herm will never know that I love them deeply. Oh was my mic unmuted. Oh you guys didn't hear anything. I swear
Let me sit back in this chair
I don't know what you heard but
Whatever
How you doing for you? Yeah
Oh big yon, oh big yon
You giving me kisses
You
You gonna have a show everybody. Oh, yes. Oh, yes
Stop looking me
All right, let me leave you alone
You
She still can't move but you can see that she moves her head pretty well
And she'll like sometimes she'll like kind of roll roll herself, but it's hard for her. What are you doing?
Boomi's chasing his tail
On the cat tree and is rolling like running in a circle
Benji who's benji
Audio clip is going on my my space page. Oh wait, there's person's name is benji. I'm so sorry. I thought you were spelling boomi
I'm such a bitch. I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry
I literally no no no no
I profusely apologize. I I do know who you are
Don't get it wrong because you're one of my regulars. I thought they were misspelling boomi and I wanted to make fun of them
You just got caught in the crossfire
I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry benji
Oh
I know how to I know that's why I know you do
But I thought you spelt it wrong that one time or like autocorrect. So I wanted to target you
Since you always you're always protecting him
Oh, oh my god, my nose. I must have dust under my desk. Where is the sound?
Sound doko
You
In a memento
I have to restart the app
Hola soy torah
Do you know where the bitch is? Do I have to
Do
Bro, I can't hear nothing
What happened? Oh my god, boomi. Why'd you have to do this?
It caught us. Yeah, you caught us straight. Um, yes, I'm a fill up all the six hearts and I unlock a new form
Uh, hold on while I figure this out
I don't know why anything is muted
Bro, this is gonna piss me off
Usually if I just restart the gox lr, it's fine and now it doesn't want to do it
What if I
What if I what if I bury me bury me?
Come
rank me down
But bury me bury me. I am finished with you. Yeah
Nope still no worky
Uh, I'm gonna quit the game and go back. Don't worry. We're not missing anything. I didn't get any get far
If I listen to my own stream if I listen to my oh, yep, it's fine
Oh god, my voice is so annoying
Jesus christ
How do you guys stand me? Oh my god
Oh my god, yeah
disgusting
um
Let me go back to wedding which
Yes, I know you can see double of me. My voice is pleasant. Oh my voice is so obnoxious
Like when I'm like when I'm like stuffy like this my voice sounds a little bit more nasally
And um
Oh, what there's a whole opening sequence that I missed
Help help help
Help
Help is it in my back?
Help is it in my back? Oh my god. I am help. Is it in my back? Oh my god. That was really weird
Because it like
Showed me to start the broadcast
And I'm like what and then I said manage and then it switched to end and then it said do you want to go live again?
And I'm like, yeah
Great. I lost like half of everyone. That's that sucks. I just lost like half my viewership
Um, I'm now officially a two of you gonna cry. Uh
May tweet that I'm back
Sly oh my god, a cap slot gone slide hiccup
My fucking nose
Here right now scratching behind me my eyes twitching in irritation
Whoever left his courage honestly, it was probably no one
It was probably just lurkers or people that came in on like a raid or something that I maybe not seen
least scoff she be streamed
I'd like to think so but that just doesn't seem to be the case
I
Need more water
Oh, you were gonna yawn if I rub her nose her mouth opens. Oh, she's not doing it though
I
Will eat be kitty welcome back lurkers welcome back. Hello. I'm you're gonna hear distant she be for a moment
What are you doing
I
Help you say I'll help you. It's tripped over my foot. You eat in 10 minutes. You can't survive
Excuse me watch your face watch your face
I
Only have honey roasted almonds when I'm kind of sick of eating those right now
And I have some I was eating some during the other stream
12 minutes to food dispenser hot witch on stream
I stole a snack for fia. Hopefully boomie doesn't notice
He's a great cat content, ma'am. Oh, no, booby's coming
Booby's mad because you can't get past the
Why are you shoving your face against it?
It's on your nose fia
Like a reset no, I don't think so
Where's your head going
Ah
It's booby
He looks so angry when he eats it's kind of funny. Oh, I see he's gonna look up at the camera
Can you hey bro bro
Can I give some to fia?
Hey, hey
Hey, he's taking it
Oh, aren't you funny sir boomies prosecutor tipped four dollars and 20 cents
delete delete delete delete delete
No, no, booby
Can you please I'm trying to give some to fia and you bit it and now the stuff can't come out
Nice freaking going like he bites the side
And so it can't come out
I was giving it to him
You can't guys he's using his hand you can't you see his hand on me you see his hand on me
You see his paw. He's holding my hand
You see this then the camera wire
It feels like what the fuck was my snack
Booby why are you chewing on it? Ow your claws are digging into me. I just trimmed them but they still hurt
Finish the mess you need
Oh, aren't you funny?
Booby tipped four dollars and 20 cents mom, please I'm starving
Would you lick the lick the part over there? Yeah
Okay fia would you lick a little bit?
Like Jesus dude
There's no more
You ate it all no
He just took it no
Booby just walked he just walked away with it. He just he just he just took it
I wish I caught them camera. Let me give it back. Hey
Give it
Motherfucker you can't eat the tin foil
He just ran away from me with it
It just got mugged fia are you okay? You were just assaulted
Is that your bean? Oh, that's your bean. I thought it was caffeine
Do you like your tooth?
The roses out oh the roses out don't go why that does sound or is it like, huh? What do you mean?
Oh
My god, my nose. I'm gonna take another allergy pill. Oh my gosh
I thought you're matching Bellator of okay, I could just get a bouquet
Okay asset what rose did you think we met?
Shut up. Anyway, it's back to the game
Okay, what fuck there's like so many this time
You
Run the poll aren't you funny? Well, aren't you funny tipped four dollars and 20 cents
People jury. I may be a simple catorny at poor
However, she be cotton boom clearly planned this filter to obstruct the face of this d o p p l e g a n g e r
Of the sweet boy boomie in order to frame him. What?
Do you think I made it a doppelganger of boomie? Where would I get a copy?
Actually, no, uh, I see his cat looks a lot similar to boomie except he's darker
Blah blah blah backlash. Yeah
I almost want to call him baklava
Sorry, I'll have to sneeze more cutely
You
What the fuck was that was not more cutely. No, I'm dying silly
Blah thank you
Thank you so kindly
I'm not framing him. You guys are liars. You're lying
You're all lying
You're all defending a man who shouldn't be defended. He's not even man. He's a cat. I'm gonna check on the tamagotchi while you guys vote
Here play with an angel bell whatever the fuck that is
He is like, what are you doing?
I don't know who my tamagotchi is hanging out with but they're kind of weird looking that's a cactus
All right
All right, we're looking at some milk boys. We're looking at milk
So I'll keep this is pretty close
Okay
Boomi has done more crimes than me just killing tamagotches
All right, let's go get that flower
Okay, uh familiar shit is terrible
So I'm going to do the attack power up because familiar shit is terrible. I'll tell you that right now
Uh 10 percent additional area damage damage taken by the witches halved and reflected to the enemy. I like that
Um, this is pretty good too camomile, but I'll do that because it's probably pretty handy early early game
Oh my god
Oh
Please don't tell me it's just gonna only give me freaking familiar shit
Did I click cackerel or the or the milk? Why am I getting these suggestions?
Let's get these absorption rates, baby girl
Give me the pumpkin
What's that like skit from like snl it's like I'm sh pumpkin
Ever get how it goes, but I always thought it was stupidly funny like I didn't get the jokes at all
But I just don't know why I thought it was funny
Let's do
Tamagotchi is yearning for death. You want to feel it just wants to eat to survive. Yeah, she's just trying to live
Tamagotchies aren't real
Fia is you're just invalidating my cat's struggle
Oh, let's do absorption rate
I have something I wish I could turn
Literally absorption is god tier
Please turn thank you
Give me that pumpkin
Oh, please don't tell me it's literally to give you familiar stuff cat food dispenser my beloved
David pumpkins it was
I don't know
Up J for pumpkins, I just thought it was like Tom Hanks his voice is funny and I don't even like Tom Hanks. It was just funny
You know what I'm gonna have some almonds
Are you invalidating your child's existence?
Perhaps
My children will for you two guys. Okay, understandable
You can't have an almond
But I will give you treats later
I think just unlucky
This is a better run though because I'm like getting more stuff. Hello
That was difficult
Okay, we're doing so now I saw I didn't do anything with familiar magic. So
The big boobah is
Oh
And now I have some explosion stuff and then it'll start dropping that to me
You know, you cannot donate money to boomy specifically
The gains I know right
Okay, let's do time attack
So hopefully we pick up better stuff
Ow
This is oh frick me bro
I wish I could aim
Ow
Oh my god, it's literally only giving me familiar stuff. I well, it's whatever
Because what makes the game is really like your power-ups, but it's literally just not giving me that hopefully
Okay, let me skirt on over real fast to the freaking flower
I'm just gonna eat this. I'm just gonna eat this. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine
I just can't let them corral me in the wrong direction
Yep, see it's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. Please flower flower. I just want the flower. I just want the flower
It's over here
Let's go. Okay
I don't have area damage, um
Additional explosion damage, I guess that would be helpful like if I could get some
Explosion stuff bribery for
Aw josh, thank you for the big super god damn bribery for boomy. How dare you?
Familiaries calling me you're not picking up the phone. Thank you for the super
Don't thumbs it up. Don't bribe boomy
Don't do it
What
Maybe I'll buy a boomy the happy meal that has hello kitty and yugioh
Um
I haven't been getting any explosion damage. So I'm going to do the iris just so I can have another
Form of attack just to save my ass right now
Because lately I I don't have I'm not getting anything
Tack radius up
That's very helpful. Oh, let me get over here. Oh, see you see how the good this is the absorption radius is helpful
Fuck the familiars, dude
Can I please get better besides familiars I can't even do the freaking thing
Well
Do I do beast level I
Assemble
I don't know corruption
Corruption is the uh, the suck like the real succubus magic. Yeah, let's do let's do
Corruption
Oh, I never noticed she got horns before
That's cute
What it's what's important is to like keep on to the thing, but it didn't want to give me it again
Bumi's thoughts tipped four dollars and 20 cents Bumi's thoughts finally some contribution around here to help with my suffering
Oh my god, I will save enough to rule this place. Oh my gosh. He better not
He's eating food right now, but that's that sounds pretty accurate to what he would be thinking
Oh my god help
What
It literally this is terrible why is it only giving me familiar stuff
Like they are the weakest in the game. I never ever play with that, but I'm being forced to
Usually it gives you like some other suggestion by now
Oh, this is a bad way
Oh my god, I was hoping to get I don't know I don't know what that does but let's try it
Please
For the love of god
It sounds like so I like I really wonder who did the the sound effects for this because they're so funny to me
Oh my gosh
Help
Oh finally sure whatever the frick this is
Okay, oh, oh don't die
Please I don't even care anymore just get to the flower
Oh my god, I'm going to die
Because of my stupid things
Help why is this flower so far away? It's right there. Please
Okay, okay, I'll be looping we looping we're looping we're looping
I'm gonna die. I'm gonna die right in front of the flower
Oh perfect finally, um
Addition to Dan move I don't I'm not using familiars
Explosion magic has a 20% I haven't gotten any explosion magic
Haiti here
Okay, so I can go big booba or corruption I'll have I'll have you guys vote
I
I'm gonna have some almonds
Can we get both no, sorry
I
Although technically I won't unlock anything this run
Because it's only five levels
They're both good choices
I
Booba it is
I'm almost on the almonds. Why is milk explosion? I don't know you tell me
I hope I like me even more now
It's so weird though, it shouldn't be giving me familiar stuff it shouldn't be dropping me familiar stuff that doesn't make any sense
She's getting married right now. She's getting married to you
I have a boss fight
Oh no, I lost an almond no
I'm close to death
I'm trying to find a pumpkin
I'm dead
That was funny
Okay
I
Got some upgrades, um
Just get some more attack power attack radius more health. Let's do it
Again just like just like I wrote oh my freaking god rena
What just happened what is leave her alone
Reina just ran over to me out of like fearfully trying to escape boomi
Kind of make the hat bigger you're right
Reina, I'm sorry. I can't have you on me right now. He's gotta let go of my arm
I
Think it's reina giving me allergies right now
I need to I need to brush her and wipe her down with and I usually spray the cats with like a anti
Standard thing. I haven't done that for rena in a bit. This almond is huge
It's huge it's huge
It's a big almond dude. Holy crap. See in the shit
Booby's not overpowering rena
It's the fact he just keeps annoying her and she gets pissed so she runs over to me
Almond thick like madam
Wait asked me myself bigger
Only rena gives me allergies. It's really funny
Reptiles are cool. It's funny. I said I told myself when I move out I get snakes, but I never did
Now I think
I would definitely I still I would definitely be able to have time to like take care of like snakes or like some sort of spider
I gave you salmonella. Oh my god. I was getting ball pythons. They're simple or like some hog noses
I
Have some really pretty morphs. I like lavender super condos
I like lavender snakes are pretty
Crazy snake lady significantly more metal. Okay, we got milk
Uh, I forget what this one is. I think that's like skinny. I need tissue. Sorry for you
Pac-Man toes. Yeah, they're pretty goofy looking
I do like tarantulas
tarantulas are pretty
I know emmy has some
Her husband, I don't know
And she has rats
I think my cats would eat the rats though a little boomy. Yeah, my rena and pio would be fine with rats
Like they'd be perfectly normal
Boomi would kill it
Oh no
Yeah, I can't remember what type of type of tarantula she has
I think it's a pink toe. I don't think it is. Maybe. I don't know. I have to ask her
I
Smell of cats would stress out the rats intensely. Is that
True because like I've seen
cats and rats coexist
Boomi gives of orange cat energy
I think he is part orange cat because he has this patch of orange on his nose
I like pink toes. They're pretty. I like the heart butt ones ever get their names are
How would you be terrified of emmy?
She's just a sweet girl. She's just a sweet sister. Which one should I pick?
How
Milk or cat girl or this potion? I don't feel like riding another pole
I won't miss summer ween. I clean up a warehouse side store for living. It's only august and skelton is already
Here
Milk okay, we'll do milk or milk too. Does it matter? I'm just gonna
Oh, I didn't mean to pick that fuck
I was trying to
Well
I meant to pick the like milk too because I was just switching between them really fast
Oh, let's get the flower
So I'm gonna be
Let's do the freeze
Is that a bee
Hi, I'm michael spelled with the with the bee
But the bee is silent
Where's the bee there's a bee
Okay magic missile is pretty good
It's pretty simple. You can't go wrong with magic missile. Oh, we're gonna prick it. We're doing everything bro
Oh, shit
If I could look the right way that would be great
Okay, there we go
It's good to like early game get them get stuff, but only works if you have good drops
See now I'm fricking wrecking
Oh
Let's do a tackery
Get god I can just sit here
See now we're getting somewhere now we're getting somewhere boys
Let me actually come down here
Get all this crap
Oh, perfect. Oh, let's let's uh, let's do some more magic missile. This is the run
Uh
Because I have a projectile I'm gonna do the small booboo
And now I'm a little more flat twisted
It's like we they definitely updated stuff because the attack speed up thing was not a thing before
It's great now. I gotta fight a boss
Everybody's crying
Flat is justice everybody you'll be okay
Oh, no, I can actually survive
Oh
I don't know where the boss is. Oh, the boss doesn't come up yet. I forgot
Oh, perfect. Give me over there. Give me let me get it before the boss shows up
Oh
Fuck me shoot the fucking missile wrong direction
Okay, projectile
Explosion
Oh, let's get the plus up projectile magic damage to be honest to do
Wait, did I click the wrong one? Oh, no, it's fine. Uh
Magic arrow
What a creepy fucking laugh, bro. What was that?
Ah
Turn around and shoot the dude
Perfect, uh, I love the supernova black hole things. Uh, let's do max hp
Uh, let's do
Time to arrow
See how great this shit is now we're rocking now we're cooking with gas
Jesus, uh
Oh
Did I get a bonus flower the fuck did I walk into a flower and didn't notice
Ooh extra gold, um, I don't care about fucking bees
Awesome, that's right. You're right. All right, fuck me
Uh, oh, we'll do the muscle then
No, I'm strong strong than flat-chested. I'm a tomboy
I couldn't do more flat. There wasn't any small breast potion
I do like the muscle ones. They're pretty good
Tom we're a tomboy
I hate the noise it makes
Oh, what's that?
I thought I really need it right now
I wish I had some area damage. Oh nice
I
Just gotta walk around this thing. Oh my god, please shoot shoot motherfucker. Uh, let's do
Critical rate
I'm stuck on a tree. I'm stuck on a tree
Ow I need health I need health
Oh, thank god earthquake
Dilling damage to a straight line. Why not?
I don't even know what's happening. Ow. Oh, I just killed everybody. Um
Let's do
Now what would be great if I can get oh health yes, um if I can get
A black hole I can suck all this towards me and get more stuff
What are you guys talking about tomboy witchbred?
Damn it, I was hoping that would be something else
Oh fuck me
I forget. Oh, that's the eye is the ceiling thing. Oh, let me do the projectile again
Could I please get a black hole that would be such a help
No, let me get the freaking flower
Oh
Damn it. No, none of these are what I want. Whatever
Now I'm a tomboy with big hips. Are you winning she be I suppose
Let's do time
Am I not allowed
Is this oh what I didn't do it another end ceiling. I just did that
This is a fun brainless game to play
Oh
We're getting gains in every direction except the chest. Oh, let's do this. Let's just place this out max it out
Pumpkin
Okay, okay, we're going for it. We're running. We're running get this fucking goo out of my face
Oh, please shoot shoot
Shoot
Stop time. Oh help help
The whole that noise what's happening
Area magic damage, uh, this will explosion damage, uh
Oh
Yes, so that means I just critical hit everything
Raise my magic tree because I need it
Yeah, let's go
This is an OP fucking flower
Oh
Holy crap, I'm destroying. Oh, yes. Yes, please. Oh, please. Yes. Oh, yes
We're cooking
Our gaming bros
I know this isn't like super fun to watch but it's fun for me to play. I'm sorry. I wanted to play wedding witch
Ha ha ha
Match
Season is fucking bomb
I'm destroying everyone
Oh
Eat my booty cheeks
I would love some help though
Oh, I don't know what that does. Yeah, you see that shit brother
There's another
Yeah, you got me you got fia. You got this uh frik bro. Okay, I guess we're gonna do hips again
Okay, I try to be consistent but
This is not doing it
Because then we literally I'm gonna do a time attack just because
So we literally got to fight the lady so we're not we're not unlocking anybody at this round
Tell me magic missiles just fucking peak
Oh
But how are you guys doing I'm cutting through them correct?
I almost missed that
Area damage why not let's let's get some area damage
Wait
Give me that
I don't know why I clicked that because I already have an absurd critical rate
Kill them kill them
I'm destroying in every direction now owl go find me a flower. Ah
They just run at me
I
At this point, I don't need like regular bouquet stuff. So
You spin me right around maybe this is my absorption rate is so important if you do it early on early game. It's perfect
I
Starting college cool when a day trip to the beach
Running errands cool. It's been closed all week deep cleaning. Oh, that stinks
That's a bummer. It's got back from a baby shower. Oh, congrats to whomever
I
Really train
Well, if you need some sleep get some sleep
Oh my god, who is between my legs? I don't this is boomy
this is rena
No, rena's rena's softer than boomy
This is this is boomy
Boomy has like rougher for
No, don't give me that look I'm talking about my fucking cats
You took a shower good because you smell. Um, can I be with you? Oh, can I be between them? You guys are so funny
Playing video game. Nice. What you playing? You just bought 2k bonds. I don't know what that means
Like 2k and like actual like money bonds or
Oh
Let's let's clean up magic arrow. Let's finish that out
Oh, shitty. Oh, brother. Where's the flower? All right, clear the way. Let's go
I could use some health that would be pretty nice
Oh shoot straight ahead motherfucker
Uh, that actually might be a little helpful to not pull back there's a freaking flower
Are you serious?
Oh
Oh my god, it literally wants me to pick everything but
Well, maybe it was a bigger again. Oh snap
Psyop and chat there's a Psyop
Hello, my fellow youngsters, whatever you'd like to participate in this
I'm not a cah
Play black myth wukong. Oh, okay. I literally I have to get that game then
I've heard so much good things about black myth wukong
What an age game this is it's not an age game
It's literally we're just I'm just a witch and I'm getting married
You know
All right, now we got a boss battle
We're gonna fight Megara
I honestly wish this game had more bosses
I'm not gonna lie. I wish there was a boss based off all the body types
That's what I thought it was when you were first fighting
I thought you were fighting like uh, like the corruption one
And I thought I would have to fight like a cat girl one
Yeah, it's edgy
What why did my body return to normal
Huh
Why have it returned here? Oh wait, she doesn't really look like that kind of voice
Why have you returned here?
You've already found your soulmate and can live
peacefully for now on for what purpose do you trespass on my territory?
Territory I'm British now
Oh grandma long time no see
She looks like
Oh, bye lolly. Did you miss me?
Yeah, she looks she looks like Albury. Why did my body return to normal? Did you do this?
Yes, your body changing in the first place was due to my power after all. I simply took back what was mine
Are you aware of how many men it requires to reduce the potions you've gobbled up?
Oh, don't be so selfish. I know a succubus like you can fill them up again in no time
Can't you spare just a few for me as a wedding gift grandma?
Stealing from me and then demanding gifts afterwards. How utterly brazen
And do stop calling me grandma, would you?
After all I've stayed youthful due to absorbing men's vitality physically. I'm even younger than you now
Right, right grandma. So the gifts
Haha, you know, I once thought that I might kill you one day, but I believe I've changed my mind
I think I'll simply capture you right here now and make you my slave for life
Wow, she's really me coded
Boomi is laying on my feet. He's laying on my footrest on my feet
Ma'am, I mean sir, what are you?
What are you doing?
Boo, your chest might be big but your heart is still so small. I guess I'll have to teach you a lesson
Oh
My god
She wearing oh, she's shooting crap at me
Let's go in a circle and I should be good. Oh wait, uh
Let me see if I can catch her in the area of effect. Oh really doesn't even turn
What's that? Gib
Can I get like some help?
Can you shoot at her motherfucker? Stop shooting at them
What is that even
To smash
Hit her just punch her
Oh my god, what the hell
Die thank god
Oh what
What the hell I had to defeat your little buddy first. I don't remember that
What the fuck is going on?
Second phase uh butterfly whatever will I fucking do?
Are you whipping me with your fucking hair? What's happening here?
Don't give me that thank you very much
What the fuck is that? Oh
Oh, let's do that
Ha ha dive bitches
Now if only let me go find she's fine. She's fine where she is
Let's go see if we can find the pumpkin that has the thing in it
Because then I can suck all that stuff towards me
Uh, oh, there's she teleported perfect
Hell yeah
Oh
This is the run boys we got this unlock brother
Unlock where is she? Oh, she's behind me. No, she's not fucking those butterflies for
Ah, that's what they're for
No, can I kill her already?
Oh my god, she's whipping her hair back and forth willow smith style just die shoot at her not at them
Please thank you
She fucking clipped and then just fell on the ground
The witch defeats the succubus queen and completes the ultimate potion with the queen's help
And so the long-awaited wedding day arrives
First try let's go look at
Oh
We killed her no, I'm kidding. No, we just made her we just made her do stuff for us
Sus on the left, what do you mean? There's no sussiness
We got married
Oh
Oh a little bit of but fang we love to see it
I love me some but fang
She'd be never followed up, but saw you listen to the artillery ambience. What do you think of it?
Also nice drunk early. I thought it was really funny because I was I couldn't take it seriously
Yeah, it's a normal ending. I didn't get any of the the body types, but it's hard to do it the first run anyways
Uh, let's go
Let's get some upgrades
Time to go
One more option when leveling up I do like that
So
Let's just make sure we have one of each actually
That's the only one I can't afford oh and that one too
More familiar I imagine I just get all familiar upgrades
Oh
I didn't even buy that but I guess that worked out meant to click the back button
So now I have hard mode so it's six stages and then stronger potions will appear
Um, so I think it's like two instead of um three. I mean just one two hearts instead of one
Oh, we got some op we literally have almost everything here when you can see we get more potions you see that
I
Don't have five poles
Um, so there's corruption
Again, I like consistency
So I'm trying to see which path is the most consistent. It seems like the corruption path is
Because
We have more chance of getting okay, so I might do the corruption
Potion seller I can handle the potions
I'm going into battle and I need your strongest potions
Like five. Oh, yeah, sorry. I only have one
How many holes do I have? I don't know how many holes do people have?
So the enemies are gonna be a lot harder
Oh
Sunburst oh my god sunburst is so fucking good. I'm actually happy. This is perfect for this run
Oh, lovely. I love this. Uh, can I get oh dammit? I wish I got absorption rate
I fucking love sunburst
Flower let's go hurry. Is there only a minute to get over there?
Yeah
Oh my god, I'm stuck in the freaking tree. What is this?
Okay, oh 25 area magic damage. Let's go. Let's go
Is area magic gonna be the fucking move? I don't know
No
Death ray
Damn buddy, um
Yeah, oh my god
Fucking fuzro dying their ass. I forgot about that. It does that
Ah, welcome to memba
Ah
Thanks, welcome
I hope you'll enjoy your stay. Why is that thing pissing? Did you see that?
Why is it? Oh, it's cursed. I have my it's a peeler curse
Get peelered. Oh, let's see absorption radius
Oh my god, Jesus christ, uh help help help
Raise that and let nobody get near me cannot be allowed. So you see how fucking sick this is?
Sunburst is so bomb
Can I get like one more power up before this ends? Cool, uh
Oh
Let's see attack range attack speed
These guys the freeze the treatment
You guys say like already you got my kind of vibe
I you know, I appreciate that because this is one of my more normal like commerce streams
Like we're kind of just hanging out or kind of just chilling
Uh, we're kind of just having a great time
Oh guys, you might have to go hips because this is it's giving me two hearts
So it means it's a special point. We have we have to go aim for hips
If if corruption, you know, and I also have area magic. So
But um, yeah, we're just chilling sometimes they can be a little bit more crazy
But we're just chilling today. I got my kitty here. How you doing Pia?
Yeah
She doing fine
Yeah, yeah
Nice yawn. Are you cozy?
It's it gets honestly any of the options are really nice is your tongue sticking out lady?
Oh, I'm just looking at me
He just loves to give kisses. He's like a puppy
I
Because you can see the corruption you see the because it shows the girls in the background
Yeah, exactly
All right, so now we're gonna move up
Oh
Yeah, I'm glad that even my more chiller streams people can still have a great time
Because we're just you know, I'm just we already streamed earlier today. We did some golf it
Um
Big big chilling during golf it that was fun. We just need just brawny just screaming at each other
Hello
Here Daniel moving forward I think that might be helpful
Oh, never mind. I didn't like that
That was a waste. I don't know what the fuck this does. What is that supposed to do? It's so slow
I forget these guys like drop stuff
Oh my god
Owl, where's the freaking flower?
Oh
Okay, it looks great. It's really fun. I think it's like five bucks. I don't know how much it is
Oh, thank you rifle. Okay. I can't believe it's been two months. I like it's about to be three months. It's crazy
I
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you for the the congrats. No, it was really fun to play
I'll place my hand up on your hip when I dip you dip we dip you put your hand up on my hip
When I dip you dip we dip that song is bomb. Remember I used to blast that song all the time
I get joe. I get you back
I'm a sick golfer guys. I told you I get really competitive
And then I lock in and then I win
People probably doubted my ability and they're like shabby's never gonna win our girl failure our scuffed girlfriend. Never
Oh, oh
You doubted me eat your words
Watches Zera now you're switching in between valour me allure members. Yeah. Yeah, most definitely
Honestly, what I think is really cool about us as you can probably like every everyone
Like I don't think like sometimes when I like watch uh, uh
like
A agency like there's probably like one or two girls. I like really like but I feel like with us like we kind of just
We're a girl's girl. We're we're pick me's, you know, we're you know, we're whores. So we're pretty enjoyable
We're pretty all around
Um
Madam is there only
I'm a gamer
Yeah, see you guys know I'm a gamer
Pick me's. Yeah pick a pick me is a girl that just like tries to appeal
to the guys
But like usually as a detriment to the uh to other women
So like for example, let's say
Uh
like this girl's just like
Being really put down and like being shit on by some guys and then this girl comes over and she also shits on her
and
Just to kind of like be more in with those guys because it's like oh pick me like like me instead like oh like
That's what that means. I'm a pick me. No
I try not to be but I know sometimes I have I have that uh
My moments. I think everybody everybody has pick me moments
I'm not like other girls. I'm one of the boys. Okay. You can't compare me like I like I play like hockey
I play video games and like I'm not going and like they try to like pretend like they're not
Like girly like sometimes they're sometimes like tomboy's
I'm a bro
Pick mealur
What the wrong I'm not like other girls, you know, I'm different like I'm not like a bitch
I
Sorry, that sounds really good against my nails. It's my starbucks cup
He is like what the hell is that? Would you like a sip do you want to sniff it?
You like it you're quite interested. It's just water
You wearing it as a hat now
It's just like what the hell you want to look up here and say hi
She's a slight overbite so her little teethies stick out a lot. It's really cute. Yeah, you're so cute. Oh, no
I'm propped to ASMR it is a cool cup
I like the like the texture is very sensory and very nice. Like it's like kind of like it's like sharp
like diamondy
I have two I have one in pink and one in this pearlescent white color
No, I'm exactly like other girls
I'm one of the bro. Oh hi boomi
What do you want? Please don't sit on fia
He's thinking about it
Hi handsome. Are you gonna be good?
Are you gonna be good and nice?
If he is like what's happening
Look how she looks the little teeth stick out. It's so funny
She beat since you said you're from the new england area. Are you boston brewin's hockey fam?
Oh, yeah, brewins and socks. Let's go
Fuck the Yankees brother
Patriots
We'll miss you brady. I don't know what the fuck else to say. Thank you Zayla for the five gifted. Oh my gosh. Thank you
Thank you so much
Although the ropes of tom brady was pretty fucking funny. We'll tell you that that one chick was cracking me up
Boomi's trying to get in the bed with fia, but he doesn't know how to go about it
Please don't lay on her though, boomi
Ew patriots fan dropped brady left five years ago as it hasn't been five years
I don't watch football
I
Everybody say thank you to zealoft if uh zealoft if you got a gifted
I do prefer starbucks over dunks. I like starbies
Over dunks. My mom likes dunks. My dad likes starbies. Me and my dad are starbies fans
I'm speaking sport
Yeah, go sport ball
Like the only time I literally watch sports is when the super bowl happens and even
I didn't even go to with my parents to their super bowl party this year because they were invited to like
I don't know some of their church friends
Um, and they're like you want to come and I'm like, no
I'm like, I'm good. I'll just do nothing at my house
I am gonna go see my mom tomorrow though because she's like, um, I haven't heard from you in like two weeks
And I'm like, she's like, are you good? Are you like are you having a mental health crisis? I'm like, I'm fine
I'm just busy
mom, I'm okay
Yeah, super bowl commercials. I don't even care about the commercials anymore. I don't even like you sometimes if I missed it
I would like go online and look at the commercials. No
Raiders, any Raiders fans?
Get her some dunks enjoy donuts together. No, I'm not gonna get my mom dunks
I'll probably I don't my mom says she wants to hang out tomorrow night. Uh
I didn't get any recording done today because I fell asleep for like five hours again. So that was nice
um
So I think I'm probably we're probably just gonna chill at chill at my parents house and just she's probably just gonna
Yeah, my ear off about
I don't know if like family stuff
And be like, hey, how are you doing? How how's it going? Oh, um, how's streaming? Oh
Oh, oh, okay
My parents know what I do by the way if you're new here and you're like I remember
Like people probably wonder do your parents know you're a whore? Yes, they do
They don't care. They know I'm a grown-ass woman
I handed my parents my first paycheck and I'm like, this is what you can expect
And they're like what and I'm like, yeah, and then they went on a date together
Um, and also my parent my mom is also, uh,
Unemployed so I try to help out where I can so I'm very appreciative of being a dealer
I can I'm not my mom is too proud to get except any handouts, but I'll like buy or something here or there
um
and yeah
Can you survive the winter when New England Association takes your north face? I've never actually had a north face jacket
I've just like shopped it for over 21. It's like really crappy jackets
Dad eyes lit up seeing the chat. I know my dad my dad is silly
Uh, my mom's just like don't tell your dad if you get any money because then he's gonna
ask for it
And not in like a bad way like my dad's not like a mooch or anything
But he's like he'll just be like can I have like 20 bucks for for wendy's?
Yeah, no, he's like but please
I bought you. I bought you food when you were growing up, but I'm like
Yeah, I still gotta get my dad his booze like oh if you guys don't know my dad is a uh
Is a bourbon collector? He loves collecting bourbon. I will have to take a picture of his bourbon collection at some point
It's quite insane
And my mom really likes to garden my mom's a gardener and my dad is a bourbon collector
Um
But the baconator that's literally what my dad asks for are you my dad? Hello? Is dad in the chat?
My dad always as like last time I talked to him. He's like so when are you gonna have me on your stream? I'm like
When you don't say my government name
If you could call me she be that would be great
Um, I probably record it. I want to do the recording of like
I think scrawny already did it where
Her dad gets the vtubers
You had a baconator today. Yeah
She'd be dad in chat
Um, my parents. Yeah, my parents know about vtubing. My dad understands that more than my mom
My mom just tells people I'm a voice actress
but my dad is a gamer and he likes to watch twitch and
Um, yeah, he watches a lot of twitch streamers. I won't be surprised if my dad got into vtubers because of me
I think he's seen a couple before. I think he's watched iron mouse because she's you know, always huge on twitch
um
My parents are pretty hip. I can't really get anything past them. So when they asked me are you gonna be doing adult content?
I was like, yeah
I'm not gonna lie to you
They're like, okay. Just don't tell us the details. Uh, but run us that check
My dad was like, hey since you're you're
since technically like
I gave you your voice acting ability because I like I make funny voices and you copied me
Like I think I should take a cut. I'm like dad. No
My dad literally was like, you know, like I helped create you and my mom's just like barely but okay
You tell them. Yeah, fam. I'm gonna be goon and no cat for a friend. My dad knows what that means
So does my mom. My parents are very hip. My parents are young. They didn't have me young. Don't get me wrong. My parents, um
But they're like they they keep up with the times because they're annoying
I wish they wouldn't so I could get past stuff past them
You know what my I already told you like I don't I've told the story before
56 I know my parents are in their 70s. They're pretty young. They had me they had me pretty young. Um, and um
Honestly not that young but I'll be young by today's standards. I think um
My parents didn't have me when they were like 16. Do not don't get it twisted
Don't don't don't get it twisted. Um
Oh, yeah, no, my mom loves tiktok. So does my dad
Uh, my dad when I told him I was a vtuber when I started vtubing
He was just like, are you one of those vtuber hentai waifus? And I'm like
This is before I was in v alert. I'm like dad. No
Does your dad have an ohshi? I am my dad's ohshi. You know, my mom's ohshi
Of course, I'm their child. Of course, they're gonna ohshi me
My dad has no shame facts
I regret my my dad will sometimes I like had friends over at one point. Um
For like because my parents
Oh my goodness
I need to see this again
Oh, it's not coming out. Thank you
My dad is hilarious. You guys will like if I ever record a video with him, you guys will literally lose it
Because my dad is very like
I don't know. He's just a cool guy like I need to have my friends over. They're like, how's your dad?
I'm like, I'm here. I'm the one who invited you
They're like, yeah, but your dad I'm like
And then my mom's just like what about me
But my mom is like my mom is more I think because my dad is very like kid-ish
And my mom is more like, you know a grown-up
Because my mom would always make the jokes. She's like, I swear I'm raising two children because you and your dad like argue like brother and sister
Does your dad
Oh, what kind of question is that? Yes. No, I'm kidding. I'm kidding. He's just not again. My parents are christians
I already told you the only the one time
My dad when my dad will say like, you know, my if you guys don't know if you're new here
Hi, my name is she be con bum. I am biracial. My dad is black. My mom is white
And I've told the story of me and my dad trying to bully my mom into saying the n-word as a joke
And she did not because my mom's a real one. Um, and she never ever has never in her life
Because she's cool. Um, but my my dad will be my dad's pretty
My dad is very, uh
Like my dad doesn't sound like hood or gangster or like whatever because the people like might assume just because he's black
my dad is very like
Very professional and just like goofy dude
He's very like it's funny because my mom is also like mom jokes
Like my mom like will make like, you know, like dad jokes. My mom was mostly does that like my mom loves puns
Um, yeah, he's my dad's very articulate
I'm not gonna say my dad talks white because that's fucking stupid. I hate that expression
um
But like my dad's a very I I do give a lot of credit to my dad and my mom for
Teaching me how to speak like being a well-spoken person
Because like with church like we had to do like speaking things and like when I went to like church school and stuff
Um, and I had to like read bible passages if I was raised christian. I'm not now and my parents are aware of that. Um
And uh, so like I my dad and my mom like drilled like stuff into me just to be a good speaker
um
And at one point I was like very particular and very like nitpicky with how I spoke
But now I don't really care anymore. Um, I'm kind of I talk more naturally because before I used to be like
very transatlantic like news person accent
Does your dad have an accent and you grow up here and lose it?
Um, no, my dad does not have an accent. My dad was born in Haiti, but he immigrated but early enough
That he didn't have an accent, but he did for a little bit and then he grew out of it
Um, and then because like it was really hard for him growing up because he had to
obviously learning english. English is a very hard language
um
And so that's why he's like super
Particular but pronunciation because he worked so hard to learn english properly and that if I say
nuclear
And not nuclear he will freak out
And sometimes I say it wrong on purpose. It's not nuclear. It's nuclear and I'm like, okay, dad
Um
Read the bible with your prayer. Yeah
No, don't eat that
Nuclear yeah
yeah
Yeah, it's like he my dad was very like particular
And my mom my mom has always been like a very well-spoken woman. My mom is very business sense. My mom is honestly
It's funny when I showed her I showed my mom my lore video
And she was just like wow, this is so me and I'm like mom
Because my mom worked in a very corporate environment. She was snubbed for a lot of stuff being a woman
um
She if honestly if my mom went to college, she'd be running a fortune 500 company right now
She is so badass. My mom is ambitious and crazy and awesome and I look up to her so much
Um, did you learn krayle? No, I don't speak krayle. My dad never spoke krayle with me
I know a couple words and I took french so I could understand a little bit, but I don't I don't really speak krayle
And it's funny. My grandmother says my dad speaks krayle crap like not that good anyways
She's like my she's like my dad speaks krayle with an accent now
And when when he's far away from them
Because he spoke it a lot more my grandparents live like you guys know in florida
um
So they they live farther away. So my dad doesn't have the opportunity to speak krayle as often
Um, like I have my cousins and stuff on my dad's side that speak krayle, but we haven't seen them in a bit
Have your parents asked to open to the triple
Because you might why would my dad speak japanese?
My dad would probably be like hi watashi wa
Verdacted like my dad would probably say that I have to come up with a name for my dad and my mom
Secret names actually I'll let them pick their own names when I see them tomorrow. I'll talk to them about it
Uh, my parents will never be open to a throttle because they're christian as hell
Oh
Although like it's funny. They're like they're cool christians
Papa mama shibi sounds good enough
Papa no, they would they would want like my dad will probably want to be called by his like gamer tag or something stupid
Which is like his get my dad's gamer tag is like, um
Like every
I'll tell you like the word it consists of because nobody's gonna find it
But it's like just like how strawney like has her dad's name as her as her dad's gamer tag as her name
My dad's um part of my dad's gamer tag is salvation
And so like when he would kill people like he'd be like, oh i'm your salvation. I'm like bitch stop
I'm like dad and then like my dad's clan was called ill
exclamation point ll
for for call of duty
So I might have him be like sal and then my mom
I don't know. I have to I probably call her by like one of her favorite flowers, which is like I'll probably call her dahlia
mama dahlia and papa sal
My dad's pretty my dad's pretty cool and my mom's pretty awesome as well
My mom is the type of woman that like all little girls would have looked up to
And my dad's just like a cool guy to hang out with like my dad's just pretty chill. And so is my mom
My parents are pretty funny
Salvation is on a killing spree
hat trick
But yeah, and uh, I'm pretty close to my parents in real like I've always got well not always because you know growing up and
Like I was a shitty as teenager
um, but
Like, uh, I'm an only child
Like kayfaba side. I'm an only child. So I'm pretty close to my parents. And so I'm pretty I'm pretty open and honest with them
So I've it's funny people are like, do you have a do you have a dad?
Like do you have a bad relationship with your parents because you do this job? No, my parent my relationship with my parents is amazing
Actually, I love my parents to death. I would do anything for them
Dahlia is a cute name human wise. It is really cute. Sal and his gal dahl. Oh my gosh. I think they would like that
I think I'll I think I'll tell them those are I'm sorry. He's here or your internet persona names. I've chosen them for you
So Chuni, my dad is very Chuni
Seems like everyone viewers good related facts like that's not even wrong
Like that's so we all have good really real pretty fine with our parents
But like I will say like for Azura, um, it's like
like, uh
The best thing you can do is move out of your parents house
Because like you can have a great relationship with them
But when you're older and you're around them all the time and you want to do your own thing
It's like annoying. So it's really good that she she needs to get out of that place
um
Sometimes her mom just comes in when she's recording and she's just like, uh
It's only fair they give you your name. Yeah, I gotta name him back
Kind of name him back
But uh, that's yeah, it's a little bit about my parents
They're pretty neat
Wish I could move out. I know I saved a lot
I was thankful because my my mom
I was paying rent and my mom surprised me
And said that my rent money was actually going towards
To buy an apartment and so I was like so happy she like organized that
And so she like handed me like a good chunk of change from like a couple years and was like, here you go
Here's your first and last and I was like, holy crap, mother
And then my mom is the one who also was able to help me
Apply for the housing lottery because like I made enough money
But like I didn't make enough money to like survive by myself like I would have had to get a roommate
And I'm happy I never did and my mom didn't want me to have a roommate
Um, so I applied for affordable housing lottery in my area. So I would have like just reduced rent. It doesn't like
Um guys, I don't live in the fucking ghetto. Okay, if people were just like, oh, she's on section eight
No, bitch, and that's fine section eight is okay
Like we people need shit. It's a lot like you should have showed up people for having that stuff. Um
But yeah, so like my however housing is reduced like normally my rent would be like 2400 $2,600
But it's thankfully 1500 although
I don't know if I'm gonna be staying this place that much longer because they are really on down my throat because I'm now a vtuber
About like how much money I'm making so it's um, and I'm trying to like organize it all
And they also need some information for my last place of work. So I have to go back to work
um
Yeah, no like I never
I never lived in the project
um
Yeah, no, it's like so I applied
For the lottery and like like filled everything out and then they selected me
And then I still had to apply for the housing
Like the actual apartment and I could have gotten denied if they could have just denied me
And so I would have had I had to go through two like things to get into my apartment building
My apartment's really nice. Like I have like a gym. We have a pool. We have like like
uh, a cool like hangout area and like, um
Like computer rooms and stuff like it's pretty nice and it's like it's a nice building
and I have um
Pretty pretty okay neighbors. Um
And they accept animals
But they have pet rent, which is stupid. Pet rent is a fucking scam
But yeah, no my my like honestly my goal is really just to buy a house
Like that would just be awesome
I don't know where I would move to though. I like I want to be close to my parents
But the rate of the cost of living in new england is ridiculous
Excuse me if you look at like new york or boston or like
Hartford or I'm trying to think or like
Portsmouth main or like a bunch of
It's like ridiculous
Yeah, pet rent is a thing. It's it's it's a scam
I have to pay $50 for each cat, but I don't because they don't know that I have more than three
I have more than one cat
Except they did find out that like one of them was there
So I had to pay extra
But the landlord lady was kind of cool and she was just like, you know what it's fine
I like simies cats and I'm like facts and she also had cats in the group with a simies cat
So she let me only have to pay for two instead of three and technically I'm not supposed to have three cats
I'm only supposed to have two
But then I was like pushing back and I was like girl
I see people with like two dogs and three cats is so like what is this about and she's like, oh
True, you know what whatever
Yeah, new york sucks
I've only been in new york a couple times, but no, thank you
Uh, actually, no, I like I like going to New York City like the like time square is pretty cool
Yeah, like oh my god, like it's so like the cost of everything is so stupid
I was wondering I'm like, should I just bite the bullet and just pay out my full rent because the application process to get
My affordable housing is such a pain, dude
And I'm like is it even worth it?
But I don't know I think I need any more time to save so I'm gonna try to fill it out. Hopefully they don't frickin deny me
Because then either way I will have to pay like 2400 bucks
I hope I don't have to move to my to a different apartment because that would be fucking annoying
I will actually like probably just move out completely then
Yeah, New York City is probably ridiculous
Yeah, it's a piece to visit not to make it rich and not tonight and everything goes well
Well, like I'll tell like I'll be like I'm obviously like really transparent with you guys
I'll tell you what I'm going to be doing with like, uh, the donothon money I get so a portion will be to pay off of my
Um debt because I ran up credit cards for this lady right here
And myself for my own health issues because I had to put stuff on credit cards and um
So I'll be using stuff for that and then probably and then 3d. That's that's what I want to do 3d
I'm like
Gee what's happening?
Boomi stop chasing her
That was rena hissing into the mic
Reina, I'm not home base. You can't jump on my desk
Hey, no, she sounds like she's spitting on someone
I
Like I don't abide by it but my area is pretty nice
um
Oh my god, my nose and rena came back up and I just rubbed my nose. Oh, no, I'm gonna be sneezing more
Um, but yeah, no, I would like to do like 3d
I already have like three projects. I'm working on what I've told you guys about
on a secret
Two I've spoken of
um
Five years ago I was 3k for renting
Really crazy. No, it's what like 5k
Like that's why I'm it's more it makes more sense to buy a freaking house than to rent right now
Because unless I move to like what what's this? I can't remember the state that has like no
No
income tax
It's a new Hampshire
Yeah, like New Hampshire, for example, super tax friendly and make more sense to rent there than to buy a house, but like, um
uh
my god
Tax-free states, bro. Let's just move to a tax-free state
Delaware. Yep
3d blue website, ooh
um
Yeah, how's it doing? I'm probably probably have to move to the south
I'm going to florida now. Okay. I don't florida is too hot. These places are too hot. I would like like
um
Like mid mid east that's not a
Direction, but you kind of why is midwest but there's no mid east make that make sense, huh?
And um
But yeah, it's like the cost of a mortgage is less expensive than rent. So like why
And then I would like want to put like effort and time into a house and like just like strong like me and strongy want like little farms
We just want like to raise animals
Maybe we'll just I maybe me maybe me and strongy will just be gay lovers and we'll just have her
I'm kidding. I'm kidding
I'm kidding. So no, I'm not moving to the middle. Oh wait, that makes sense
Listen to east coaster. Yeah, like people already people already, um
You know 2k townhouse. Oh my god move to I'm moving to canada. I actually liked canada because I had some um
When I was a youtube commentator, I had some friends in canada. So I went to visit them
um
I will actually know there wasn't the reason I was I had a I had a bachelorette party
uh
And we went to matri all and then my friends happened to be there and I was like, oh, let's hit take out. Um
And
Like she was showing me her place and I'm like, why is this so nice and then the air bnb. We stayed in was so nice and then
I was like, can I live with you and she was like, no because you need to like have citizenship and I'm like, but just sneak me in
Never get involved in the land war with asia
One of the classic blunders california is really bad too. Yeah
I'm like, I was like, I don't know. Maybe like washington. That's like across the freaking country
Um, because washington's a lot like new england
Yeah, there's a lot of canadian vtubers and I did not know this
Uh, what do you mean new england we get nor'easters we get we get rocked by snow brother
Canada is number one be down live in toronto again. Damn
Damn
I don't have any canadian citizenship. I have technically have Haitian citizenship, but I am not going to
Yeah, can he I that's like I thought what like Ian
Was predominantly american
But then I realized as I was streaming that everybody's from canada and I'm like, what the heck
Or they're from europe and I'm like, that's so crazy. But the rent said, yeah, I bet it is cheap
This winter was easy. It wasn't easy winter. You're not wrong. The summer has been super fucking hot though
Asian canadian presence in the e and v2. I yeah, I suppose so
Haiti prices are not looking nice enough though for the gang violence brother. No, thanks
Michigan oh
One third of you're not wrong. Yeah, yeah me and is our american
Amy and mercy are canadian
And then I was gonna say strontis european, but she's not in scotland anymore. Um
Yeah, I see I see. I don't even know where I see it isn't actually within Europe
Mass prison break, I don't know. I don't keep up with that because I just get depressed
I just get depressed because I've always wanted to go and now the country is terrible
We are the are we the most diverse
Corpo, are we the most have we hit like I think we're the most diverse corpo. Yeah, you got
Mercy's Vietnamese
Amy is
Uh, I forget with what her nationality is
She's well, she's canadian, but she has her ethnicity
Uh, actually, I can't tell you because then um, because that's I know where she went for her family thing
Uh
And that's where her family is from that's what she is but she's diverse
Um, but she's white. I see is
Uh, I don't I just know I I don't think I see is ukrainian. I don't know actually
Uh, stronti is scottish
This rise you're even telling us this much. What do you mean? They they people I'm telling you things people already know
I'm not spoiling anything
Is I see check I don't I can't remember
Just ask her
What are you she's asleep right now
This is all unclassified information this is yeah, I guess I already know this stuff
I spent I am asked I'm like please stronti. Please can we get a spanish girl and gen two?
Can we get a spanish girl? I want a spanish girl
please
Eastern european everybody everybody's eastern european besides me and erzura
Who means running around and fios watching him
What are you
Gen two spoilers, okay, what do you mean? That's not a spoiler. I'm just asking for someone who's spanish
Because I would like a spanish speaker
The spanish speaking isn't on tap market
I know a little bit of spanish, but I don't know enough and I wish I like I again
I had a lot of like dominicans near me growing up
And I'm wishing I I took spanish and still french because I know I use more spanish than I do french
Kehonda
Horny that's no that's that's an accurate that's very accurate
You know welsh girl
Are there no there's I think there's a girl that's welsh and like globy isn't there?
I didn't know cdog v uh va was uh welsh
Vila, well, I want a japanese girl. I want a chinese girl. I want a spanish girl. I want
A german girl and I want
And I want why is my wine out help
Can I can I get rid of it?
I'm dying
I want a portuguese brazilian girl get a get us happy
No, we're kidding. I hope she's doing fine. Oh my god
I want to be the most diverse freaking company ever
Hola senorita con Yeta se ve muy bonito
Trey grassy ass
Just kidding
I don't know what that means though
What does kanyata mean
Bunny
I don't know my animals leave me alone. I knew it was a compliment, but I just didn't know that part
Little bunny. Oh, that's cute. Okay, let me I forgot that I was playing a game
Have you been liking the yap because I naps for so long. I'm not tired
Wait, there's a game. Yeah, there's just spooky noise in the background for no reason. Oh my god, my throat is itchy
Let's do a
She matched HP
Like I forgot what I'm doing
Those are the noises you guys make when I'm jorking it
Starfall
Oh fricky yeah, brother
Ow, I'm walking into stuff. Oh owl
Wish I could aim the correct direction
Lifetime up
Oh
No, I wanted the flower
Can't get the fucking flower
I
Hips hips don't lie
Want to move one to aim. I'm literally just doing my arrow keys and then that's it
That's all I'm doing and pressing z when I need to confirm something
Law hips
I need my sunburst to be stronger
I get some health
No, okay bit
And I get an owl owl fine stuff shoot
That's not the direction I wanted you to shoot. Oh, that's fine actually
Oh, what the hell
Oh, damn it, I was hoping it was health
It's us when she uses the whip I just laser beam you
Oh
Oh, I'm so stuffy
I'm so stuffy won't you stuff me?
I should probably tweet about the new audio. I'm just totally forgot about it. Oh my god frick, bro
I swear to god, I'm getting this stupid fricking thing
I have 20 seconds to get this stupid flower
Give it to me
Oh
Oh my god
Can I get health or not that's fine
It's just like homelander
We're putting it all in hips, baby. All right, let's keep it up
No, I hate her new finger. Was it good? I don't even remember which one it was
Is
Hips don't lie
What is what these mo that's what you guys sound like when you're finishing
Oh
I might die actually this isn't good
I need health. Let's go look for health
Please black hole sure how that is
What
I'm David pumpkin
I don't know what the fuck this energy orb does but sure
Oh
Oh my god, okay, at least I have time to go get this stupid kill. I mean stupid flower
Oh my god
Health health
Uh juke them just juke them juke
Oh, thank god
Give me some respite some respite
Okay
Which needs food is there somewhere where you guys sound like they're pushing weights into chill. Is that true?
I think how true it is because I've seen how guys lift like they're gonna try to kill god
Oh
Be so funny too bad these are shit flower
Oh my god
Please help help help
I
Was pretty nice. Yeah
I'm gonna die no I don't want to die
I don't want to die I'm gonna die. I don't want to die. This is a good run. I don't want to die
I don't want to die. I don't want to die. I don't want to die. So you're gonna have to
Like that. I like the remix of that the dubstep remix pretty fire
No, I literally had like one health
God damn
I was so close to getting the hip
Hips don't lie. Hey pro tip when you run out of it. Do you want to fucking?
Don't get sassy with me motherfucker. I'll get your ass
Yes
He got shot
I'll beat you up. I'll punch the mic punch the mic punch the mic
Hello 9-1-1 I just
Hello wait, holy fuck
Hello 9-1-1 I just witnessed a murder she be cotton bum just fucking nuked a guy
Just join us
Get plapped. I mean get get whatever. I'm just gonna stop talking
I'm hungry
I haven't eaten since two get corrected get corrected
Please don't do the arthur morgan type. I don't know what that is
This I just have a megaphone on
Excuse me
I
I'm dying
Gunshot vicham tipped three dollars and 33 cents. I lived she be underscore smug
Well, thank you gunshot victim
I
Wait, should I should I sneeze in reverb?
Let me let me sneeze the echo and reverb
We turn that up. Oh god
Okay
I'm not sick. I just have allergies. I'm so sorry for scaring you by getting a tissue fiat. She just like twitch
Oh
Little girl, I'm so sorry
Oh, it makes her yawn
Like lick lick. Well, well, well, well
No, I should take a girl such a good girl such a good girl
Well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well
No, no, this hurts. You have a rough tongue, ma'am
I know you're just trying to be nice
by grooming me
Because you see me as a giant dumb cat
She's still licking me
Are you done?
Ready
Okay, she has my hand now
She's very thorough. She's making sure I'm clean
I
This is my hand clean yet fiat
Okay, I'm just gonna take that away from you
I
Say hi to the camera
She looking at ya her sparkly eyes
She be stinky, uh, probably because I have a shower to like two days for three
Fiat is a Siamese cat mix. She is a
Uh blue point
Blue sorry lilac links point Siamese
You know, it's really weird
I don't smell as much now that I haven't shaved my armpits in a while
Like I know I don't sweat as much and it's very interesting to me like I don't smell as bad
Like I don't know I just smell like it doesn't smell bad. It just smells like smell. I don't know how to explain it
Oh my god
Why are you still licking me? Here, let's flip you
Let's flip the baby girl. What are you doing?
Time to flip her like a pancake
I'm sorry. I'm not gonna do this with the camera on though. Just in case I knock it down
It's time to
eat
There you go
Hi, no you're making it flip like a little pancake
Yeah
She has been flipped
And I can pet your butt
Oh
You see how she opens her mouth when I rub her nose
She gets so happy she's smiling
She is so calm yeah, she's in a giant big fluffy bed like the bed is bigger than it seems
Oh, I don't know if you guys just heard me crack my buddy
It's just a it's just a tissue
Two cuties cuties with booties
I want to play until I unlock somebody
I should probably take like I don't know hopefully this would be the run
Okay, we did corruption last time and we went for hips as well
The hat oh, you're right. I have to make the hat bigger. I bet you guys thought I would be dying a lot more often, huh?
My hat is like going over chat now
Let me move you guys here you guys can go up here
Well, you did. Yeah. Well, you did suck my cock. How about that? Um in Minecraft
Let's just let's do
Oh
Let's click on this one
That's because you haven't gotten it yet
All right, if it gives me familiars, I'll do this stupid familiar
Well, why'd you give me health?
Give me that HP baby girl out
I guess I need it to the health because I'm acting stupid right now chain explosion. I don't know what the hell this does
Oh
All right, let's fucking bounce
There it is
Bomb
B
XP
Spider lily will be good. Let's do that. I'll prefer more XP. Oh shit
Let's do is there speed no angle range
Oh my god, what the hell oh fucking familiar
What the hell is that noise miss what does that even fucking mean?
All right, let's do no, I'm in it. I'm in it only do it if necessary
Uh
Just
It's the bird doing something I don't fucking I don't know what this chain explosion is I'm gonna do absorption rate though
Oh
Stop time. Oh, they get pushed. I didn't even notice that before. Oh perfect. I was getting closed in there
Oh my god
I
Don't know what this chain explosion thing is this is doing something. Oh now I see it
I'm like, I don't see anything happening. All right. Let's get the stupid feathers
I'm telling you feather. This might not be the run
Because the familiar like the familiar potions do like
Jack shit. I'm not gonna lie to you. They just have terrible power and just like area of effects and all that jazz
I can't even tell if it's doing anything to them
Come on I will do more
I
Now this is the run for sure
I'm gonna play wedding which with you wish me. Oh, good luck. Good luck. I hope you enjoy
Okay, so I can go beast or small boob. What do you think?
I'll do a poll for this because they both have super so they're both super potions
Flat justice
I'm gonna turn off auto target. Oh, I didn't know that was a thing. Wait, did I know that was a thing?
I forget
I'm dying
Oh my god
Almost pulled the camera down
It's funny because I think the last time I played this game
I literally had a sneezing fit and I had someone when I was streaming on twitch on my pl
They came in and clipped every
Sneeze and it was like a hundred and something
Oh sneezing hurts because like it makes my like body tense up and like it's not this doesn't feel good to sneeze
Oh, that's painful like I like sneezing but not like this
Am I okay? I'm okay
I can sneeze like I'm like a dragon ball character
So
Oh, that was that hurt I shouldn't have done that
Is my nose bleeding hold on if he is staring if he is no if he is actually asleep or all that
I thought she was looking at me
Is my nose bleeding it's not
I'm gonna go take an allergy pill. Yes. I already took something. I'm gonna go take something else. I'm dying
I
I feel I'm so sorry for making you
Oh
My god help I'm dying slowly
Someone come take care of me, please
I
Actually
Haven't gone anywhere
I
Be a this is what I have having for cheap
You guys can see it
The camera get booed
The hell
Out of the camera get booed
I must have sneezed and pulled on
I don't know why backwards but flip it. I don't know
I
Violent sneezing it's because my camera wires across my
Lap
Might as well take my meds while I'm at it
One of my meds actually also doubles as anti-history. It's very funny to me
But to my dish and it so much oh it would oi
Yeah, yeah, how are you doing? You look so pretty in the purple light
Oh do harlots of dander
I don't know you guys
Oh, I'm like sweating what the hell is happening am I sick?
Oh, I'm like super hot a little scrunchy even my hair up. Oh my god like dying
I
This is where it's going to be.
The air conditioning is on.
This is how it will be.
Rainbow, come here.
You gotta find them.
Tia!
Did you follow that okay?
Not much you're choking on me.
Don't bite me.
Move me, go away. There's like 50 others on the floor.
You guys, you guys, you're crying with me.
You guys, you're crying with me.
Ow!
Fucker, hit me.
No, it's okay.
It didn't hurt.
You're so good.
Can I have a kiss?
Thank you for the kiss. Where are you going?
Thank you for the kisses.
There's no bite on my fingernails.
I love you.
Hair reveal?
My hairs are a ponytail.
I feel the bite bed companion.
Both.
Take a look.
Harlots vs. Reflings cry off.
Well, they, I don't know.
They might, They might beat you on that.
They've had a long time to cry.
To like save up their tears, you know.
I'm sorry, I'm waiting for my tea.
She'll be done in a second.
What are you doing, Bumi? I don't trust you.
Stop chasing her!
Bumi, enough!
Stop! Leave Reina alone! Why are you terrorizing her today?
Where are you? What are you doing?
You look fucking suspicious.
I feel you. You stay cuter, Bumi.
Bumi, stop being a menace.
You've been crying? I want you to cry right now. Cry.
Cry for me. Cry for you bitch.
Just a minute.
Smashing water everywhere.
Cry for me.
Okay, I got some tea.
What? What are you looking at?
What do you want?
She like head nods to me. She's like, wait, what's up?
She always does that because she always wants to know what I have.
It's just tea for you.
You're so excited. It's not a treat.
It just gave you treats, lady.
You made me a sweater with my tears.
No, I want you to cry, IRL.
I want you to cry on the chat.
I want you to just shut a tear for me.
Pour one out.
I feel like I sound like Doki Bird right now.
I'm like, I'm a little bit, she's a little bit more easily.
I'm dying slowly.
Are you still Doki Bunt?
I will try, try harder.
You were working.
Yeah, I was working on the thingy.
I want you to just shut a tear,
like pour one out for the homies type.
You're so cute.
Doki Bird is awesome.
No, let's not say that.
Let's not go there.
I'm barely a doll myself anyways, so.
What did you guys vote for?
I don't even remember.
What did you guys vote?
You got one tear.
We voted flat.
They're not even small.
They're like normal sized.
You have some tea.
I need it to cool off though.
It's very hot.
Yeah, go cut an onion.
They're cuppable,
but they look huge.
I don't know what you guys are talking about.
Those look so big.
She gets flatter than that.
Are you thinking of milk to make yourself cry?
What are you thinking about
to make yourself cry right now for me?
Yeah, they were humongous.
Now they're just huge,
and now they'll be normal sized,
and then they'll be flat.
You don't have milk?
Why are you crying?
Why are you crying over milk?
It's not even spilled.
I'm thinking about what you'll do to me
if I don't cry.
Cry bitch.
Cry, cry, cry, cry for me.
I need boy tears.
My tears will heal my soul.
Tia, you're looking at me
with the cutest expression.
Why are you so adorable?
Why do you look so funny?
Stop, don't lick me!
I know she be tomorrow.
Yeah, it's working.
I'm crying.
Why are my eyes, hold your eyes.
No, boomie, don't chew on the camera.
Camera cord.
Yeah, I'm not going to be here tomorrow.
Cry about, boomie!
I'm not going to, sorry.
My demonic tone.
I just took, because he just went back
and did it again.
I'm thinking about stubbing
your little toe.
Boomie didn't get his chicken nugget.
Boomie throwing the camera.
No, he's chewing on the wire.
It's next to my computer.
Yeah, you don't have me tomorrow.
I'm hanging on my mom. How does that make you feel?
I'm thinking about all the injustice boomie faces.
Where's the Lego? Yeah, go step on a Lego.
Boomie.
I'm thinking about how my cat's legs don't work.
I'm thinking about how she can't do anything.
Besides,
sit there and eat hot chip
and do crime.
It's terrible.
Not the NTR.
That's not stop!
Don't even go there, dude.
You guys know how I feel about that stuff.
That's messed up.
She'll be fine.
Don't worry, she's going to get better.
Well, no, Sundays are my days off.
So I can actually get shit done
and like
run errands
with the stores and clothes on Sunday.
Okay.
Let's...
I'm going to make jiggy cookies.
And sweet potato fries.
Get away from the freezer.
What do you need?
What do you need from the freezer?
I think I'll have five nuggets.
I'll have a five of these nuggets.
Okay.
Is that five?
One, two, three, four, five, okay.
Sorry, I have three couplers.
Let me get away from the freezer.
Okay, you're going to hear my air fryer.
My air fryer is going to do its thing.
You know, fry that air.
Can't wait for FPS week.
That's good.
All cats born after 1993.
You only need a hot chip.
War crime person not walking.
What?
I made no message about it.
I said nothing about a date.
Excuse me.
Normally I eat my burps
and save them from member streams now.
But that took...
I can't do anything right now.
I'm falling apart.
Nine out of ten.
You guys are all lying to me.
You guys are only...
Hold on, I'm going to fart.
Why did it squeak like that?
Was that a bugle?
That was so funny.
That was like...
That was like the tiniest...
Squeakyest too.
I thought it was going to rip ass
and it came out like...
Like what the fuck?
Oh my god.
She said that that was members content
during the master disguise.
Then you did went to media.
Yeah.
I give you guys like a little...
I dangle you something every once in a while.
I just wanted to do it
because I like seeing you guys' reactions.
I do a lot of stuff
just to get a reaction out of you guys.
Just the sweetest.
Is that hot to you?
Me just doing...
I'm dying of sickness
and this is what I offer up to you.
This is members only content
so you should consider member.
Exactly. I rip ass and I rip so much.
So if you're into that, come be a member.
And if you're not,
you can mute me
when that happens.
I'm not into that.
But like...
I think you guys just think it's funny.
I think half of you think it's funny.
I think half of you just want to hear a girl fart.
Sorry.
A third of you think it's funny.
A third of you just want to hear what a girl fart sounds like.
And the other third is just like
I'm jorkin' it.
Can I mute them in members?
I do. Okay, I'll stop.
I'll stop.
I don't think... No.
I don't think I've murdered...
Fuck me.
Muted.
First in members before.
Why not all three? I'm in the funny group.
I'm part of the jorkin' squad.
I'm mad. I'm sitting on my face
and tooting on me.
I'm making my own members content.
Yeah, I don't really think...
If a girl did that on stream
while I was watching, I would be like,
funny. I wouldn't really care.
Yeah, let's take a poll.
Let's take a poll.
I put fetus instead of fish.
Okay.
Wait, I accidentally did caps lock.
I accidentally did caps lock.
I want to hear what it sounds like.
Nice job.
You maxed out small titty. Nice job.
Good job.
This is for science. Be truthful.
Be truthful, please.
Damn, a lot of this is funny.
I'm laughing at my own caps lock error.
I want to hear what it sounds like.
As a squelcher,
it doesn't squeak.
Stop tooting.
Why?
I need an explanation as to why.
Just tell me why.
Tell me why?
Why don't you?
Even if it was anyone, I think it was funny.
Party is a natural thing.
Alright, I'm walking over here now.
I'm going to shake up my food.
I'm going to eat my food.
Crispin up.
Honestly, you guys don't know that's what I'm doing.
Only by the light of my computer.
I don't even have any lights on.
Yeah, I'm comfortable with you guys.
Also,
why don't people like tooting?
question why cuz I've seen like some people be like oh my god it's fucking
disgusting but you fart too bro I'm sharing an intimate moment with you like
just accept it open your mouth and inhale my fart you don't have to fatter
it's just funny it's I guess I'm a child then I guess I'm just immature
she be you don't know already you don't turn the lights when it gets how do you
know that are you watching me right now through my window I'd be impressed
cuz I'm on like the fourth floor so no I can't do all that
no I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding with you yeah I'm just curious like you
like you too I too everybody toots everybody hurt who's this boomie hi
boomie he's looking his toes under my desk all right it's very interesting so
people just think it's funny that's fun that's fine don't meet we're all bros
here yeah click come on you don't you hang out with your bros you just like
rip ass in front of you like each other like isn't that a thing go don't guys do
that but they don't then you're not really bros
everybody
It's all New York, and that's how it's gonna get to me I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I've got to
do this, I've got to do this, I've got to do this, I'm gonna take my love in here
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
And boomies, stop.
Stop trying to get in the bridge!
I'll just try to get out of the way.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Coz I have no money.
I can't get around the function.
Oh.
How does a fricking labor though?
Is it not.
But China.
What it is, ia.
If this god knows death, he doesn't.
You know, I have like a package of like,
Polynesian sauce, this one's good.
So, this is a good spire.
We're gonna have issues with trying to hop in the fridge.
Well, he likes to jump in the fridge,
he likes to jump in the dryer,
he likes to jump in the washing machine,
he likes to jump in the dishwasher.
I don't know why he's like this.
Ta-da!
I did it.
He is like what the fuck?
Are you trying to make it undetectable though?
Yeah, do whatever besides the car.
I'm just gonna stick this on my keyboard.
But we's hungry too, he literally just ate.
Excuse me.
What's the brokerage?
4 out of 0.
That's nice.
He can't have sweet, well actually no he can't have sweet potatoes.
Nomi actually likes vegetables a lot.
He's the only kind I've met that likes vegetables.
He is just like sleepily looking at me.
What's the bro quiz?
Nomi's vegan.
I explained so much.
Can you imagine?
I have honey mustard ketchup and then I also have some Polynesian sauce.
And then Bumi's on the desk and he's probably gonna try to steal my food.
Can I help you?
This is too hot for you to eat, you can't have it.
No I know the bro code, they said the bro quiz.
I can't see but he's walking around my desk or trying to.
Trying to get around Fia to get to my food.
Are you guys gonna cry every sentence?
How much of a bro am I?
I don't know, tell me.
Shime body erotic.
See Bumi's tail.
Bumi what are you doing?
I'm trying to eat.
Do you want us to?
Yeah, continue.
It brings me joy.
I like watching men cry, it turns me on.
What is that?
No Bumi, you can't have it.
Bumi looked at it like what?
Locked in. Target acquired.
Tani much more.
Target acquired.
Tani mustered.
It's our turn to be men Hiroshibi, what if we cry and we don't want to?
Don't want to what?
You don't have a choice.
You think you have a say in the matter?
I don't care, I'm doing it anyways.
Am I hot now?
What are you doing to her?
Yeah, cry, cry.
Cry.
Cry for me, cry for me.
Hiroshibi you didn't read them.
Read what? I can't read, I'm eating.
I'm trying to also, I'm my guard for Bumi.
Mascara would be nice.
Guys with makeup are hot.
Cause they're bisexual.
Get it cause I'm gothic, sorry.
I love sensitive by guys.
Drinking so I can cry more.
When did the shippity get here?
Shibi's filtering the merrows.
I'm very gothic.
That's Bumi jumping down.
I was like, honestly I'm so sick of reading merrows.
Like I looked again this morning and you guys had like responded with really nice stuff,
but it's, and I love it a lot.
But it's like nine times out of 10.
It's something like really like manager larpy or annoying or like, and I just like, I can't, it's not fun anymore.
And I'd rather just interact with you guys on stream like this.
And then like someone who's just like, oh no, please don't be cute and funny.
I'm like, cause I don't, cause I don't think I can love you.
And I'm like, then don't say you love me.
Like that's just so disrespectful.
Like, you also don't know anything about me cause I used to be cute and funny before I was Shibi.
And I'm like, I don't think I can love you.
And I'm like, then don't say you love me.
Like that's just so disrespectful.
Cause I didn't think about me cause I used to be cute and funny before I was Shibi.
Yeah.
I demand more soy sauce videos.
But like, you know what?
If I change, like if I do a 2.0 and I'm a fucking dog and I, or I do this or I turn into like a
2.0 slime girl or and I'm cute funny or whatever the heck.
Like if you don't want to stick around, you're totally entitled to that,
but you don't have to tell me that you don't like something.
I'm going to do what brings me joy because when I'm happy, I make better content, you know?
Like, so if I change my appearance, then yeah, I'm not changing my personality cause this is how I am.
So like, you don't have to worry about that.
But like, that's like a year away.
People are like, oh my gosh, she's doing it now?
Oh no.
And I'm not, I'm not doing that for my 2.0.
I'm not being cute and funny for my 2.0.
Yeah.
It's like, I'm still the same person.
Doesn't matter what, what I'm piloting, you know?
I don't know what website I need to go to.
Like that just solidified for me that they don't love me for me.
They just love me because of what I look like in a body type and that made me really sad.
And then I know you're like, she don't get one guide.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I know.
I'm not getting one guide.
Cause I know a lot of people share the same sentiments, so.
I'm dropping you.
It's not an airport.
You do not have to announce your departure.
It's like, and I got like, I understand what like, I can sympathize with like them saying it makes me uncomfortable.
Comfy, but like, it kind of confi...
Cause I'm like, I'm going to be the same person, just like chibi, chibi, chibi, chibi, chibi.
And it's like, I would just be cracking like, so I don't really get it.
Like I'm not, I wasn't going to like, I'm not making a 3D model of that.
Like, no.
So like, I understand where they're coming from, but in the context, it still doesn't make sense to me.
Like, I should literally have strong Italian people that like, Kayfabe doesn't mean a shit in this company.
She just, she literally is only for Patreon and people still can't get that through their head.
Like, I am going to be myself on YouTube.
And this is how I am.
I am just a dork.
Sorry.
Sorry, I'm like, I'm truly like a fucking animal.
My bitch chibi got me acting up.
It's just a little alt-model.
I just wanted a little fun, like, chibi model.
A little cute, funny model.
Cause I thought it'd be fun.
Because I guys, my PL used to be cute and funny.
And I miss being cute and funny, so I wanted a little cute, funny model.
But that won't be for a very long time because that takes time and money.
People are like, oh my God, she's changing her whole thing.
Muppet chibi.
I told you guys that Toma made a 5 2D model on that, right?
She made me a Muppet Life 2D model.
I haven't been able to use it because she's learning how to rig.
She wants to be able to rig her herself.
I'm not a freaky, honestly.
Like, yeah, I just, I wish people would unreal-
And that goes for all of us, like, not just like me.
Like, the kayfabe is a, is a suggestion for streaming.
But Patreon, it's yeah, but like, otherwise.
Like, I'm not going to use a cute and funny voice doing my Patreon audios.
No.
Toma is cooking.
Yeah.
So like, I got it.
If you don't want to hang out, if you don't want to stick around because of that,
I totally understand.
You're totally entitled to that, but you don't have to tell me.
You just tell, like, you telling me is just going to make me bitter against you.
It's not going to change my mind.
I know you think you're doing like constructive criticism, but it's not criticism.
You're just telling me you don't like something, so you're hoping I don't change it because of just you.
Which is kind of like selfish for like other people who are looking forward to it.
Or just like me and my happiness.
You're putting your happiness before mine.
Because you gave that as a reason.
And like, again, I'm framing this in the form of like a relationship.
So if like, if your girlfriend comes to you and she's like, I want to get this dress and you go to her.
And she's like, I can't wait to get this dress.
And she's been talking about getting this dress.
And then you tell her, I don't like that dress.
It makes me uncomfortable, although she's been talking about it and showing you updates about it.
And you're like, because it makes me uncomfortable.
So I don't think I can like be with you.
Then just go like, you don't have to.
It was from the very beginning that she, I talked about this dress.
I feel like, yeah, I was like kind of worried because I know Emmy used her real voice today.
And honestly, Emmy's voice doesn't sound any different from her, her voice acting voice in my opinion.
She really doesn't sound any different to me.
I can't, I'm not good at telling differences like that.
She just sounds like a little bit deeper and that's it.
And I love her natural speaking voice.
And I was very worried that people are going to be mean to her, but it seems like everybody's okay.
So that's good.
Because like, yeah, because it's like she wasn't, I think she just wasn't feeling good or something.
Or she just was like tired and couldn't keep it up.
And like, like she shouldn't have to like, if you love someone, you love them no matter what.
If you only love them on conditions, then you don't, you're just infatuated.
You're not, you don't unconditionally love someone, you know.
But then again, you're entitled to, she's a 50k, 15k.
Oh shit, nice.
But again, if you're entitled, again, in a relationship, if someone makes like a crazy change,
then of course you're entitled to leave that relationship,
but you don't have to shit on the person on the way out for how they are, you know.
Yeah, Amy, Amy was like, I love Amy's natural voice.
She sounds hot either way to me.
Like I would listen to her.
Like I just honestly, I like how like, cause I like talked to her and call like I talked to her yesterday.
She was, she was chill with me cause I was kind of like a little bit stressed out as you guys know.
She was like, what's going on?
So I called her and she's just like, you know, talk like she's, she's very, she's very level headed.
So like if you're a pen pal and also like a harlot, like she's, she's, she's a real one.
She's good.
Um, yeah, she's always hot.
Yeah.
She'd be a shorts.
What?
Yes.
Question.
Um, but yeah, like she was like, she wants to get like, if I was a cute and funny, then I would also do the cute and funny voice.
Like I, but I would also probably be like Amy and be transparent.
Be like, Hey guys, this isn't my, she's like literally her first stream in her 2.0.
She's like, this isn't my real voice.
Like she told people so long ago and people freaked out back then and they, they, I don't know if they freaked out now.
But, um, I think she sounds amazing.
She's a great voice actress.
That is just because her voice, she doesn't mean she's changing.
It's more like she's even more relaxed.
It feels more comfortable with people that she wants to like share that part of herself.
And that's, yeah, it's like, people need to like, like we're feeler.
We're so open and honest with everyone.
Like I don't think people realize how open and honest we are.
It was any other company.
They would not give a shit about your feelings and consider like stuff and talk about stuff and be transparent and honest and open.
And I don't think, I think people take that fucking for granted and it pisses me off.
I'm sorry.
I'm kind of like ranting.
Um, but like if I was in a company where they're like, you are this and stick to it, then I would, but I'm not.
So I'm in a company that lets me be myself.
So I'm going to be myself.
You know?
Yeah, it's like, you know, we did throw the VTuber rulebook out the window.
We're cool.
We're chilling.
She's like, yeah, she literally, and like, it kind of makes me sad.
Like I said it in my, like when I responded to someone's mayor, I was like, I know maybe men had a, but these rats are delusional and crazy even for me.
Because sometimes people will take something and just like go so far with like, I said, so like, I'll explain to you right now, like what happened when I took the log down the other day.
Um, I didn't like, I'm still on great terms with that person.
I just didn't know their PL and their PL affects our relationship with other stuff.
So I had to take it down.
That's a little, it was really that simple.
It had nothing to do with that other person and their identity.
Like it had nothing to do with that.
Like a little bit because I didn't realize it.
And then I was like, oh no.
Um, but that wasn't why I was apologizing because I noticed it like, uh, like during stream actually.
Um, when I was like dying, when I was like dead and not in the thing.
And that's fine.
Like, like I understand it's not going to happen again.
And if that did bother you, I apologize.
Um, uh, they are still in a lovely, amazing person, that creator as well.
Everybody was amazing.
That was a great collab.
If you guys saw it, you saw how much fun I was having.
So it's like, it was fun.
You don't want to contact them.
Exactly.
So like, I like, I realized I talk too much.
And honestly, I feel like I need to talk less because I sometimes I overshare and I over like kind of explain my feelings.
And then that leaves room for people to misconstrue and kind of like put in their own narrative.
And I really don't want that to happen.
So I'll probably just like not do that anymore.
Like I realized I need to be kind of like kind of more chill like Emmy does or like I see or Zura or Mercy.
Like everybody else besides myself in the company to be honest, because I just, I don't shut the fuck up.
Like that's just my, that's my thing.
I don't shut up.
Um, even on social media, like it's also because I'm alone.
I have no one to fucking talk to.
The other girls, they're also alone, but like, I don't know.
It's like they have family and stuff.
So they have other.
So like, I just feel like I need to talk and talk and talk and fill a silence besides talking to my cat.
Oh my God, look at Fia.
She's like curled up.
Um, yeah, like I always make that joke, like, uh, move in silence.
And I'm like, I literally need to do that though.
I need to shut up.
I like, cause I know my tweet.
Like I was still like joke.
Like, you know, I was joking this morning about like, uh, that like VTuber meme account or whatever, like blocking us or whatever.
I think I don't actually, I don't think they blocked a Zura.
They, I think they blocked like everyone else besides a Zura.
Um, but it's funny.
And, um, and so I was like, what?
I thought we had something special, but that's like jokes.
But I like, I bet there's someone out there that was just like, I can't believe she's starting drama with this.
I'm like, no, I'm not.
I'm just memeing.
I'm just joking.
I'm just, I'm just messing around.
I'm kidding.
I'm joshin.
I'm jorkin.
You know?
Um, you explain and talk more and still listening to people to know what to do.
Yeah, exactly.
Uh, I followed you.
She means I was doing like Harry Potter today.
Yeah, I just, I don't shut up.
I don't just shut up about myself cause I like to talk cause I'm lonely.
Please save me.
Um, but yeah, no, like it does seem like it's causing problems.
Like it does seem like it's causing extra stress cause I know some of you guys like in my messages,
not my messages, my, um, comments were like, are you okay?
You'll be okay.
No, it's fine.
And like you guys were stressed out and I don't want to stress you guys out just because
I'm saying something stupid on my own.
You know, like, I don't want to put you guys in that situation where you stress out about
me or feel scared for me or you think I'm super sad and you're upset because I'm upset.
I don't want that to happen.
Like, of course I'll be honest with you.
Like if I'm upset, I'm going to be like, Hey guys, I'm upset.
I don't like this, but I don't want to, when it's not that deep, I don't want to say something
that people like run with it and like freak out about, you know?
Yeah, text is hard to cover.
Yeah, it's hard to detect tone and text.
So like I want to be more careful.
I'll probably just like, again, I'll still tweet a bunch cause like I don't shut up,
but I'll just like, like Strani did.
She's like, you know, you know, I know you, she didn't say it like that.
I don't want to say something that people will fucking take and run with.
Um, but strani is like, we should probably not like message negative stuff on our like,
on our all accounts because people will sometimes like take it and perpetuate a cycle.
I'm like facts.
I'm like, and I like was reminded of that the other day.
She didn't remind me or anything.
I just remembered it.
Strani is like, you're fine.
I don't have to worry about you.
And she always like checks on me.
She's like, are you good?
I'm like, I'm fine.
And she's like, okay, fine.
Good.
That's all I care about.
Um, but I'm just like, I don't want to stress out.
People are make a perpetual cycle of like, you know, like people making rats or like,
um, just like thinking something's bad when it's not on a big deal.
And then like, yeah, I just like, I don't want people to be stressed out.
Um, came from the booba staying for the actual human relatability.
Yeah.
No, I'm, I'm a normal person.
I think the thing that makes me a little pretty cool is that we're all pretty chill.
Yeah.
I'm going to try to be transparent, but like still have an air of professionalism.
Like I'm, I'm going to like, I like being man head up because, um, for the, just for
the reactions and the memes.
Um, but I realize I have to like reign in like sometimes I'll like, again, like people forget
that I used to be a YouTube commentator.
So sometimes you would say something inflammatory, get a reaction to get more content and that's
not a good idea with becoming a Vtuber.
It's not a good one.
Um, it's not this, like I'm still adjusting to how the community works.
People forget that I've only been a Vtuber since last October.
Um, I was a Vtuber.
I was an indie Vtuber for six months.
Um, then I got picked up by Viller.
Uh, I ditched, like I was a streamer for five years before that as a fast streamer, but
in a, in a content creator, but I still don't like the community is still very new to me
and I'm still learning how it works.
Although I've done, I've done all my research and I've looked up stuff, but then again, um,
it's different when you're in a situation and how people react.
Uh, but yeah, does that make sense?
Yeah.
Thank you.
A little crazy, never hurt.
But like, I just like, I don't want to make you guys sad.
Like it made, like it hurt me so much seeing how sad some of you guys were, you know, and
Boomi, what are you doing?
Boomi's laying inside of my blanket.
My blanket's like on the floor and he's like curled up in the blanket.
Like I'm holding, I have a little bit on me, but he's like, hold it onto himself.
Name every Vtuber.
I got you.
Um, no, but I did because I was very, I'm just new to a thing.
So I like, I know my special self decided to do so much research and watch so many videos.
And I like, I caught up on drama that was like years ago, just so I could stay in the loop when
people talk about stuff.
Like there are some Vtuber stuff that happened like 2020 that I don't know about.
And I was like, Oh, let me do some research.
Oh, who is this secret person from an agency that never technically moved forward because of this
whole situation and blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I was like, Oh, um, feeling like at least present.
Yeah, you know, but it's like, but like, I love making people happy.
So it gives me energy.
Like I like, it's literally brings me so much joy to make you guys happy.
Um, I don't, that's why like another reason why I'm so like worried about people liking me
because I like, I just strive to make people happy all the time when they can't be happy.
And it's due to me.
I get upset because I'm like, what am I, what do I, what can I do to make you happy?
But then again, I always have to remember I can't do everything.
You know, like I have to be realistic with myself, but I try.
Um, I try to like make people as happy as possible because I just all until I want, I became a content
creator in general because I remember, and I've said this story before, sitting and watching
YouTubers like freaking PewDiePie and Markiplier when I was like coming home from school, come
home from school, sit down on my living room floor and turn on the YouTubers.
I didn't watch TV.
I watched YouTubers and, um, get laughing and feeling good and feeling like I'm hanging out
with friends and, and like Jenna Marbles and stuff.
I freaking love Jenna Marbles and, um, I'm like, I want to be able to be a creator that
gives us for other people.
I want to make people happy.
I want people to come home from work or from school, sit and watch me and be like, wow,
this is great.
This is fun.
Um, Markiplier, she's not dead.
You don't have to say RIP.
She's just, she's not, she's not content creator anymore.
I'll watch Julian from time to time to check up on the dogs.
He is, he is dreaming and her eye is open, but her like secondary eyelid is over her eye.
So she looks like she's possessed.
Um, she's not dead.
No, I miss her.
I'll watch her old videos.
Like I'll literally come for a watch her videos.
Um, yeah.
Jenna, Jenna was awesome.
Yeah, I do.
I, I, I do care a lot.
I do care.
Um, and I try my best and I like, I'll, I'll like, um, take Hania's sneeze again.
I'll like, um, kind of take the brunt of stuff, um, on the chin, just, uh, just to make sure
people are happy.
Cause that's all I want.
I don't want to, I don't like causing issues, but I feel like, I feel like I over, I over
try to fix, cause I'm a fixture.
I over fix things and I try too hard and end up, um, um, oh my.
My eye is watering.
I love overdoing it, um, but I don't mean to.
So like, I just, this has been a very amazing experience for me being a Vtuber and a content
creator on a greater scale because I'm learning a lot about myself.
So thank you for that.
Thank you for this growth opportunity.
I appreciate you guys.
No, I know.
Like I was fine while I was eating my food and then I just died again.
I'm glad that I can help you guys feel less hopeless.
I'm so sorry.
Like I know some of you guys go through stuff and you come in and you use Vtubers and as
an escape, cause I like, I do the same thing and I use streaming as an escape cause like
after the real world, man, for real, for real, no cap, facts, printer, no ink, no ink.
Um, I promise you I'm not crying.
I'm literally just dying from my allergies.
Um, cause I know you guys say I'm a cry baby too.
You get it.
You can chat with flex streaming.
Um, but yeah, I know people go through shit and like I'm very sympathetic to that and
I'm pathetic to that.
So I get it.
Did you come at a bad time?
Yeah.
I was going to make a really bad perverted joke, but I'm going to stop.
I'm going to stop myself.
No, I'm just sneezing.
I'm just sneezing.
I have really bad allergies, but thank you for showing up.
Your streams are really entertaining.
So, oh, thank you.
Yeah, I just like, I like my chat interaction.
I just like talking to you guys.
This is, it's as great for me as it is for you cause I know the serotonin people get when
I talk to them, you know, so premature fewer.
Why do you have the Brazilian flag when you're covering your nose?
Are you using that?
Are you using the Brazilian flag?
That is disrespectful.
Brazil.
I remember some lady, like somebody was speaking Portuguese and I was like, Oh, do you speak
Portuguese?
She's like, are you Brazilian?
I'm like, no, I just know what Portuguese sounds like.
She's like, Oh, sneezes in Brazilian.
Oh, okay.
No, I made the Sculpa.
Okay.
Got you.
The Brazilians hit.
That's the way for a moment.
You died.
I wish I could like, I need an overlay.
That just lets me do the you died screen when I will like just feel like it.
So I can play it on games when I'm not even playing.
I was like, Hey, you're better than 99%.
No, it just sounds like it sounds like I'm pretty.
If I hear it often enough, I can know I can differentiate.
Like I knew like when he was like watching a video on like, um, what it was, it was a
like putting on the outfit for like VTube studio for what she got from booth.
It was like suddenly like Mandarin.
And I'm just like, I thought Amy was speaking Chinese.
I like looked, I wasn't looking.
I was like doing other stuff.
Excuse me.
Cause I was feeding Fia.
And, um, I'm just like, I'm like, is it me?
I was like, Oh, wait, no, that was not her.
Well, like, I like, I like, I can tell this like Chinese doesn't sound like Japanese or Korean.
Um, and I, I always, uh, a lot of my, I remember my customers in the past cause I had a lot of
international customers at my last job cause I worked in sales and customer service.
But I, they would like to talk and I'd be like, Oh, you're speaking in certain language here.
They're like, how did you know that?
Do you speak it?
And I'm like, no, I just pay attention.
I see me somewhere.
Portugese.
No.
Does that mean good night?
I don't know.
I don't, I can't read Portuguese.
Portugese.
To be honest, I'm too shy to actually speak up.
90 times for some of the time I'm hanging out on streams.
I start feel guilty for saying too much of stream's attention from regular to deserve it.
That's not true.
You are a regular.
You're just a lurker.
Like, don't worry about it, bro.
Don't worry about it.
I'm happy you're here either way.
You're not taken away from anyone.
Everybody, everybody's happy to be here.
Everybody's happy to be together and hang out with people that also have a common shared
interest of a Vtuber that they like, that they can all support together.
Why do you think Azura's Dorothon is so successful right now?
Which is awesome, by the way.
Like, holy crap.
Like, it's great.
You know, everyone's welcome.
Yeah.
Like, we love lurkers here.
16k.
Holy crap.
That's how much I'm in debt.
Yeah.
Like, I lurk streams.
I get it.
Sometimes I'll mostly lurk streams because I don't want people to, like, call me out and
be like, oh my god, chibi con bum.
And then I'll just go on my alt if I'm super, super worried about that.
Because sometimes I do want to talk in a stream.
Yeah, we're all here to get justice for boomy.
No.
Yeah.
Like, honestly, I was like, Shani was asking me, she's like, what do you want to do for
your Dorothon?
Like, what are you thinking about?
And I'm like, I know Azura put hers at 10k, but like, I might start mine off at 5k.
Because, like, I don't think anybody's going to donate to me.
Because we're all just like, like, we're all so new.
Like, why would anybody donate such a broad amount?
Like, I'm like, I'll see how Azura goes and then we'll see.
And then Azura's blowing it out of the water.
And I'm just like, holy crap.
Like, that's amazing.
I'm so happy for her, guys.
Like, you guys have no idea.
She needs to get out of the house.
She's just so much happier.
And like, I know she wants to be productive and like, living there prevents her from being
productive.
And then like, I know that I also help with our like health stuff.
So I'm just, I'm really happy people like actually came together.
I know some people like don't like donathons.
And I totally understand that.
But like, think of it as just like the opportunity to just crowdfund project.
If you, if you come together to crowdfund someone for something, something for someone
that gives them more motivation to work on projects.
Like, again, I'm using mine to pay off some debt and then work on projects.
And then since I have less debt, I have more money to put towards projects.
Guys, I pay, I pay for my own games.
I paid for all the outfits.
Like I sometimes put some of the outfits on booth, but I decided to stop doing that.
I set up a lot of stuff.
I spent $200 the other day getting stuff together.
I spent another $100 for the summer.
We need to like, I put money into my streams.
Like I put effort.
I know the other girls too, too, immensely.
So I, it's awesome when people see that support, recognize it and want to give back.
Thank you so much Snufkin Nate for the 20 gifted.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
Everybody say thank you if you got one.
Nice.
Nifty.
I need a sneeze.
Choo!
Lurkers got lured out from the gift.
Thank you for nice coming.
Oh, thank you.
I appreciate it.
Well, yeah.
I need a sneeze again.
Choo!
Are my boobies trickle every time I sneeze?
I don't know.
Are we dodging gifted?
I know.
Yeah, you don't, you don't get the much either.
Where's that one gay harlot?
I think they're greedy now.
Because we have to get a different account.
The feet look so nice.
I don't sneeze that much though.
It's literally because I have allergies.
I've listened to any Brazilian music.
Yeah, I have.
I've listened to Brazilian music before.
It's pretty good.
I like listening to different countries music.
As people know, as I blasted.
Some..
El Alfa?
Just, when I was fighting..
Margette.
Margot, Marget..
Margette the Fellowman..
I need drink.
I might throw..
I'm debating so.
I'm debating whether or not to pull out
black myth Wu Kong on thrown..
I might just have to buy it myself because I don't think it's available on throne yet. So I'll probably just buy that myself
And instead I'll put a new mouse on throne because my mouse is fucking dying. Does anybody have any recommendations for mice?
Three for three with the free member. Let's go
Yeah, that's true. I'm a bot one
You're just like I'm gonna get people gave for me. That's all right
Did I ever get the hoodie? Oh, yeah, I got the hoodie. I just got it
Um, I did just get the hoodie, you know, it was really funny. I put it on. It's comfy. It fits me really well
It's not as oversized as I want it to be because my boobs are so big
I was like really bummed by that I like really that's why I got like I ordered like an extra large. Oh
And I'm like my booby too big
Man my mouse
No, so the thing is I used to have a logitech
I had the same one the shroud uses and I had that for years and then I
I don't know what I spilled in it, but like when the keys got sticky. I try to fix it didn't work out
I'm ready to have this logitech key 305 is really good. Okay. Thank you. Thank you now
um
and
I'm gonna crack my neck and now I'm just using I used a backup like a mouse
I just had which is the razor one. I think what is this? I
Just have a razor death at her chroma. I've had this one for it's honestly. I've had this one for
Probably like eight or nine years
I've had this death at her chroma for a while. It was just laying around
um, I
Usually use lot yaw logitech or razor perfumes. I remember I remember I
Like my first giveaway ever one was for a logitech headset and I was like, oh my god. Now. I have a razor black shark
um
Pro I think I don't know and then I have
The razor black widow and then I have a razor. Yeah, I use I like razor a lot
Like razor is pretty good. It's just kind of like, you know brand hype and stuff. I get sponsored by razor. They're sick
All of all the the quartz stuff because pink is my favorite color. You guys know light pink. Oh, I love light pink
Um
You have three death hours double. Yeah, yeah, I've had this for a while though
Like so I'm surprised it lasted this long this this mouse. I did but like what's the I had a
Yeah, I did 303 before it shot up
Um because shroud uses it
Yeah, I got it for like literally like 40 bucks
Brand new first time I had one. I've gone through two
The second one I got scammed on because I got it from eBay and somebody like I asked if it double-clicked and they said no and then
Double-clicked one immediately when I got it and I'm like, dude, is it me but I had other people use it
I had my dad use it and he was like, no
He's like, this is the mouse and my dad my dad's a tech guy
He he will work on the fixed computers too. So he's like, yeah, no, this is this is junk
I don't like damn it. So that's when I you start using my razor
Again, I be so cool
So not raising I never heard of that
Trackball nice really nice 70 carpal tunnel issues trackball
Look and then my mouse is going because like I was using it earlier before I started to stream
I thought I was gonna have to cancel stream because my mouse completely froze and the tracker the laser wasn't working at all. Oh
My god, my magic kicking in making me sleepy shit
Yeah, I know it's it's it's it's 1155 for me I
Could say wait owns. I don't know how to say it in Spanish because I know
Once I don't remember
Shabibi
Yeah, I take something called
Adarax, which is good for
Insomnia, but also for like just generalized anxiety and it's also doubles as into histamine
um
Which is because it's normally antihistamine
One say do say yeah
And so
My mom says it's my diet Xanax, so I started calling it my diet Xanax. I usually sleep because I have insomnia
I don't even know why I have insomnia. I've just always had insomnia. My dad has insomnia, too
I'm like, it's a genetic thing like I didn't think insomnia was like that. It's fucking stupid
You say I'm out. I don't know what that means
He's being Portuguese and I wish I could understand you
Dyes
Now I forget what the other name for it is
But yeah, I take that for sleep and then I take my my other anxiety man cuz I have anxiety I
Took I started taking um
my searcher lean because I
Like for I don't I said this before like for six months
I like was really agoraphobic and I couldn't leave my house
And I don't like now in hindsight. I'm like why but I was just like I was just so I
Was so terrified of people
Cuz I I did like a temporary work from home job and then like it was hard for me to leave my house now
I'm fine. So that's it's crazy how like irrational stuff can happen
I
Got depression
Anxiety and depression
It's basically yeah, and pretty much is but the strict prescription better drill not gonna lie knows German
Cool, I don't know German. I only know English
Terrifying people that's a destiny. Yeah, they're all they're all dicks people in New England are so cold
Like when I went to Florida, like they're every so pretty nice
Everybody's so nice and warm and fuck cuz it's like, you know, it's warm there. We're all we're all cold and hard up here
Yeah, rock hard if you know what I mean
18 achy cowboys, sorry hard
I
Heard wanting to miss
She bad dick it does that yeah, you know, like that's how I was though
I had anxiety like I literally couldn't so I made it so get a do tell a health
That's my suggestion you I did tell a health and I hate talking on the phone
I had my mom with me to help me like you need to find someone that can assist you and
Then because that's the hardest step is like making a phone call and like talking on the phone is hard
I got a g autism anxiety depression etc. I'm probably other things too
You got the you got the whole you got the royal flush brother
No, like yeah, like I like I have dysthenia which is my long-term depression
But I haven't really experienced symptoms for that in a long time because I manage it
Well, like I go to therapy and I meant I take my meds and then like I do stuff
So like I know I come off as being crazy, but like I honestly
Um
Some of it is put on some of it is cuz again like I said cuz I liked seeing your guys's reactions when I act out and
But like
Yeah, mostly so much cat bow
No, that's it that's the same thing like I like and it's funny cuz like you like I had I had to say I could not
I would didn't want anybody to look at me. It was literally that I did not want anybody to look at me
So I totally get that and like I was having some really like
Insecurity issues and I was I was fine. I'm the same as I am now
But it's like sometimes your mind just like really shits on you, you know, so I get it
I need to cure my depression is money for sure honestly, that's that's so real
That's so real though. It really is
um
But yeah
She views are Elmo
Well, it's like I like I know like guys don't usually have the like the space to talk about that stuff anyway, so like of course
Of course you like you can do that with me. That's fine
Like I'm allowing it right now like normally it's in like I don't like this stuff
But it's like obviously in the context of what we're talking about
I'm not gonna be like shut up or only gonna talk about my trauma
Like sometimes you need someone to like tell you like hey, you got this and I'm telling you all now
Like hey, you got this like you guys are probably going through something right now
Some of you and I'm like, hey, you know, you got this like
Think about all this shit that you've been through before and think about where you are now and like I bet some of you guys have been
Through some shit and you're still standing so give yourself some credit, you know, like I remember like
Like I'll do the same thing for myself. Like sometimes I'll be like, oh my god like
Holy crap, how am I gonna deal with this and then I'm like, you know what I've dealt with way worse
Like we will all be okay, you know, we'll be okay
My sleep ASMR helps you I'm so glad
Okay guys, I think I'm too sleepy to finish this so I'm just gonna talk to you
I can't focus because my my meds have definitely kicked in I can feel it
And it's gonna make me tired so I won't be able to focus on this
But I will probably like I kind of want to play this again
I guess I just like wedding which a lot
Yeah facts ain't that that's true when he came I happen is so many people don't have to pay for their health. Oh my god facts
My anxiety seeking and heart still going to college while working part-time 32 hour. Yeah, that's hard. That's difficult. I used to work 40 hours
And I worked with people all the time
So I totally it's stressful because it's like for me
It's like a lot of stuff I can't control and like unknowable stuff so it can be a little distressed
But you got this you got this don't worry about this
You'll be okay, you'll make it work and in the end when after you after you get everything sorted out
You will boomie. Can you not chew on my headphones?
I'm trying to make it as a motivational speech and boomies chewing on my headphones
You'll come out on the other side and you'll be amazing and then you'll be way better for it, you know
Max would ask what was wrong if I was having a told her her responses. Are you really upset by that? Oh, that sucks
That sucks. It's like you definitely gets hard. I bet it's hard to like you got to find a partner that will
um
Listen to you and then you know check to see if you want a solution
Or if you just want to be heard
Because sometimes people just want to be heard, you know, like sometimes people just want to vent
Like you don't have to like I like I know like my friends would come and tell me stuff
Like I'm like, oh, you want me to fix it and they're like, no, I just want to talk to you
I'm like facts. Okay. Let me work on that
Um, so I've worked on that and now I'm I'm way more understanding
and sometimes you need someone to come to you and be like
uh
You can tell them about stuff and then be like, okay, and then
just like validate your emotions and stuff and then
You know come up with a plan of attack if you want to or just like, you know, just give you a hug
It sucks even for small stuff
Like I like as you can come to me and be like someone ate my cookie and I'll be like, bro
Fuck them like honestly
Or I could be like, let's make a plan to kill them for the cookie. No
Yeah, of course
Sometimes sometimes just guys people need to hear stuff and like I will be like
I'm glad to be that person to tell you what you you know, you need to hear in a moment
Yeah, like
Facts
Yeah, not immediately trying to fix it
This problem is something that took me a long time to learn to do and I like I still struggle with that
But thankfully not as much like I so yeah
I wish good things for people over. Hope she's treatment
Yeah, that's like that's a good point. That's a good point
Yeah, she's again, that's an X. She's X for a reason. She's not she wasn't there for you
So I hope you find someone a lot better that actually like takes care of you and validates your feelings
Everybody deserves that everybody deserves someone that like
Will hear about their their feelings and opinions and give them give them the response that they need. Everybody deserves that
Good night
Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night. You know what I'm saying. You know what I'm trying to say
I got some killer social anxiety and continues to go into doctor's appointment and searching medicine. I know
Yeah, oh someone who has gone through like a rigmarole of stuff
Um, it could be especially not knowing if something works and stuff take could take like a couple months to kick in
It can be really annoying
It can be really really really dumb
um stressful stressful moment
but like
And it but then it takes I know it's taken me like years to like find the right combination
And then like I've switched and stuff like I was on different stuff before that worked for me
And then I went on something because first other stuff because like before I had like prozac for depression
Like more like anxiety stuff. So they're like, oh, let's try this instead. I'm like, okay. Sure. Let's try it
I'm like, oh, this actually works fine. But like it takes time and money
I didn't tell you guys how much
My meds cost on my new insurance because I didn't want you to get mad
Oh my god
This is repenting. I'm super appreciative you to learn you're in particular
But do you look loneliness and you've all really helped? I'm so glad I'm so glad because like I know
I want you guys to guess how much it was. Um
Again, has someone who also struggles with loneliness because I just love my three cats
Like this is really helpful for me myself as well. So you're not alone in that
Everybody deserves some like companionship. We've always say like, oh the internet like, oh, it's not real
I'm like, no
Sometimes the internet relationships are the most realist ones
It was not one K. No, it was it was it was like, I think like a hundred and fifty like a hundred and forty dollars
How much is my urgent care copay, I don't even remember I don't even look at that
You've had two thousand dollar meds before thankfully they're not that much
Thankfully they're not that much like because like uh, my like my dad's diabetic
Just like genetics and stuff like not gonna lie to you when I hit a certain age
I'm probably gonna end up being diabetic because like at a certain age everybody's pancreas is just shut down
in our family
And um, like my dad had like ration like I've said this before like my dad had a ration as insulin before
Because it was so expensive
And then he also my aunt and my grandmother who also have it because the genetics and stuff he had to like
Give that like he would ration his insulin out to them because my dad usually orders in advance in cases of crisis because he's smart like that
But it's crazy
She's wrapped and she's at 17. I would have kept going until 20
I would have been like we're gonna do what we're gonna push but that's really all my that is insane
That is insane
Oh my god, like that's so crazy. I'm so freaking happy for her
That is wild
Oh my god massive azu w facts
I don't know why I'm saying facts so much because i'm tired dubs dubs all around right fia fia's asleep
Mama azu read yeah because i'm tired i'm like the medicarean stuff i'm tired
But guys you can always like
Like there's a time and a place for everything
But like if we're obviously like talking about if i'm talking about like
This sort of stuff like of course like i'm gonna give you a safe space to talk about your stuff too
You know like it's okay. Um, I want you and then like oh is there what the fuck?
What's she doing in here?
Yeah
Oh, is there a raid at us? Oh, I thought you meant you were raiding me. I we were gonna raid asura
Oh my gosh
Hi, hi everybody. You just ended. Okay. I got you. I thought okay
That's awesome. That's awesome. I'm so glad as there. I'm so proud of you. I'm so happy. I'm so
proud of your community for coming together
And supporting you in this way and it's amazing and i'm so
Happy for you. Like I just I can't get over it. It's like it boggles my mind
Like I can tell you probably all of us like we're like, okay if we ever you have first donor phone
It's probably not going to be that much because we're small
But you guys really came out and you guys were like no we want to invest in you guys
We want to invest in the company. We love you guys and that it shows like it shows
And we we care for you so much because of it. Like thank you so much for giving us the opportunity
To do what we do. It's all because of you. Thank you guys. Thank you
Thank you bleeding hearts for real
Everyone here
We love all you girls. We love you too. Like you guys don't know like we really really care for you guys too
Um bleeding as there. I heard you turn up when you got my letter. I heard that
I heard you were starting to cry when you read my little paragraph
And then you try to recover when with the with the woman's age thing
um
But yeah, but yeah, make sure I'm I'm very I'm very thankful for
Having such a great community. It's absolutely insane. Like we all like I'm gonna say we like
We all are in general
Like I don't see this anywhere else. It's for real. I I can't I don't I'll go into
A chat I go to this place and go to that place. I'm just like
It's not the same. We're a different beast
What do you mean me cry?
Did you guys make her cry?
Like
Yeah, literally get fun to get fun to get that's that's that's so true though
Because we want to be realistic. That's why I was like, oh, maybe like it should be smaller
But like how could you just do plans and a lot of stuff?
That's a bit. Oh, yeah
Oh, that's so sweet
Happy tears happy tears great tears. I'm so happy for it
Like it's truly like she could finally get out of the house. She'll be
Want to be more productive. She'll have some happiness. She'll have her own space
I guess you guys don't know how important it is to have your own space
Um, you might love your family, but it's still like great to have your own space. Uh, when you're when you're older
That's why I'm I'm glad I had moved out when I when I did because like I love my parents
But like I was about to like choke my mom out
In Minecraft that wasn't real. It's not like I meant like you guys know what I mean
But it's hard this is in this in this day and age. It's hard. It's very very difficult
um
Very very difficult but like I yeah, I wish I wish everybody the best when it comes to that
Wait, did you guys see is is mercy streaming or are you saying it was mercy did mercy read to I don't know
um
But uh, yeah, we're all very extremely appreciative of all of you. It's it's great
Um, yeah, now she can get her own space mercy was in here. Oh, was she I didn't see her the chat was going fast
Thank you mercy. I love you mercy. I'm so sorry mercy
Mercy if you're still here, I love you
I had a great like I like I was talking to mercy the other day too. She was like we were talking about stuff like
I just love hanging out with everybody. It's good. We had like there was a moment where um
We were all kind of like quiet like we we were all busy like, you know
People were on vacation people were sick. Oh
Um, and I was we were all just kept saying that this core like oh, we miss each other
We need to hang out and so like the golfing collab today was like very much needed
You're kind of moving on immediately. Yeah, hell. Yeah, so happy for you
Mercy was here
Yeah, I hope she hopes but we're sure we're sure safe move. Sorry. I'm I still have my allergies and I'm a little stuffy
So that's why I sound a little bit nasally today
But hi, if you're new here and you're coming from azura's raid or whatever, um, mercy's mercy stream
Um
Before she rated into azura if she did stream today, I don't know. I'm very tired. Um, my name is shimi cottonbump
I'm your favorite girl failure. Don't feel there's dead one
And I'm just kind of like I don't know the last like 10 minutes 20 minutes
I've been like gassing everybody up. We're just we just been chappin. We've just been chatting
We just been having a good time. Um
We just been kind of just like talking about our feelings and stuff
Because like we like that we do that here mercy was not streaming. I just went to a call. Is there oh
I'm like delay. I didn't look at the schedule or anything. Hi mercy. I love you mercy
Thank you for stopping by with the rest of everyone mercy
um
But yeah, it was it was a really great day today. I think we all needed that
Um, I've I've been saying before like everything feels off, but like everything felt right today. Like I woke up
I'm like, it's great. How the gulfa collab. It was awesome
stream today was great
Azura did a great job
It's like it's just it was a great day today and I'm I'm just very thankful
I'm very
feeling very blessed
Um to have such a wonderful community. We all are truly
Again, I don't think you can look around and say the same of anybody else
um
but yeah
mercy for a
a maxi bucky
um
But so thank you. Yeah. Thank you guys so much for
Just sharing your love and I hope like you feel the same like you feel that we give that love back to you because again
When you guys support us and don't think and I don't just mean like monetarily by the way
Like when you guys like a tweet or respond or share a video or whatever talk about us like
that's
That's what we can't like we don't
We we came
We joined Vila for a reason and we did we are the founding members. We didn't go into this thinking that
We were going to just like
Take over the world and make bank. No, we came in because we saw
A vision we wanted to change the community and I think we're doing that one step at a time
feel our love a hundred percent a hundred percent feel their love
um
And it's
It's great. Yeah, like it everything counts from you guys like again. We wouldn't be where we are without you guys
It's you like so i'm we're going to thank you profusely. So thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you
Thank you. Thank you so much my cat is sleeping. That's fia by the way and
Bumi is crawling into a bag
You can probably hear that
um
She was right I talked about Vila girl's friend minding promise you chance. Yeah, like check check us out talk to us about your friends
and like once
And like you guys are also the reason like other
Audiences are also looking into us because of you guys because they look at us
They look at you guys and i'm pointing i'm pointing they look at you
They look at you. Sorry fia
They look at you and they're like wow their audience is actually super nice and they're super welcoming and they're super cool
And like that's the reason we go up is because your influence and your personalities
um as a collective
Are very inviting
Like I never see any issues like I know people like oh get people like as a joke
But like nobody really does in terms of like they want us to see us succeed. You want to you
any mini by me you
um
You you want us to do well. So when people come in they're like hi i'm new
I don't see people just like being mean like you guys aren't mean you guys are great. Um
Yeah, and i'm happy you guys recognize our hard work. Yeah, give me that's why i'm like give you guys self credit pat on the back
Give yourself right now do it
Do it give yourself a pat on the back right now fia's looking at you
do it
right fia
She's yawning. Do it right now
I've been eating affectionate and yeah like you know
We're little we're little goofy girls. We're little dorky. We're little girl fails, you know
But we're also whores and that's what counts now
I don't know why i'm being so motivational today, but I um sometimes people just need to hear stuff
So again, thank you. We love you very much. Um
You're all very very cool
Very very sweet
Couldn't do this without you
Very thankful for you. We all are very thankful. I know I've strani
Me and strani were talking the other day and strani was just like I thought everyone would hate us
She's like I didn't know if it was worth it and she's like
It's not that's not we're that's far. We're far from that people love us
People want to hang out with us people like she's like i'm so happy and like i'm happy because strani's happy because this is her
Baby, she's been working on it for such a long time. Let me get out. What are you doing, dude? It's like walking across with us
Um
But yeah, it's it's so great
But yeah, if you ever need motivation, I'm here. I'm very good motivational speaker apparently
um
But yeah, it's it's just
It's nice. It's nice to be part of something big
And as we grow like I can't even wait to see what the rest of
You know
The year brings and the year like when like or i'm on gen two comes around like I feel like we're gonna get so much
Done and we're gonna accomplish so so many things
And it's just oh, I just can't wait. I generally can't wait to see
I can't wait to see the projects or the other girls that come up with
I can't wait to do the content that will make I can't wait for the collabs
I can't wait like it's it's so
It's so surreal to me. You know, it's not even been three months
It's not even been three months
Like every big like like any other company we've ever had our bumps in our rough patches
It's like these growing pains and learning how like we work with each other and how we work with our audience and how we work with other people
And like the type of content we make and like that's all fine and good
But like that and that's that's a part of it like that's a part of growth
Like as a company and so like i'm thankful for what we've been through like and that's not even been a lot like
I'm making it sound like we've had like bazillion major gaps. That's not even true not even remotely. Um, but it's like
Like of course like we've made a couple mistakes as anybody does but we we immediately
Realize those things and we immediately adapt and that one makes me happy and we're like, okay
This isn't working. Okay, we're gonna try something else like so it's
It's nice
As a shine man, i'm trying to express myself more. Oh, sweetheart. You got this. Don't worry about it
Can't wait for the slime girl slime girl gen four, baby slime girl gen four
You guys heard strani during the free she like I feel like she's doing
She's just like I hate slime girls
I'm like strani. No
Please please. I just want to slime
I just want a slime girl gen four. I'm
Does he know
Can't tell no, it's like I I remember in call. She's like, I'm so sick of hearing about slime girls. I'm like, I'm so sorry
Stop the slime girl. Hey
So
Can't believe we're talking about gen two this early, it's certainly me
But the thing is like but like like strani is a very amazing business woman and she's been having stuff in the
like
Waiting the wings for a while because she's already been working on stuff
um
So like in terms of like gen two development from what I know
um and then again, you guys have to understand like making models in like
Conceptualizing and art and like getting all that stuff done takes a very long time
So it's good that she's getting on it now to be honest with you. Um, she's great at planning ahead. Amazing actually. Um
Like she's helping me with she's helped helping me with my, um
Jonah don't don't fund stuff early so I can like get ahead on it
I have cat hair in my mouth. It's okay. I got it. Um
But like, um
Yeah, no, she's already she's trust me. She's already gotten stuff rolling
I don't even know
If she's like finished stuff some things at least like conceptualizing. I don't know any of that stuff
You guys have to ask her and you know, uh, strani will tell you like the reeflings anything
Because because we mean her the same with me. It's hard for us to keep a secret. Um,
I know on it. Yeah, I always I always look at strani
I'm like I neither grinds it
And like it me inspired me to like do those scripture shorts things
So I got that to go in like my my gen mates inspire me
um a lot
And they they guide me a lot
So I'm very thankful for them
But I don't know like cat is doing booby is like
Booby
What is happening? What are you on?
But he's like on top of something I can't even tell he's attacking a plant. That's all I'm gonna say. Um
Yeah, they reeflings got that insider knowledge
Imagine the back of a concept art
Oh my god, I told strani my strani. Please help. Well, please let me help you with the names. Please
Please please please please, um, I did give her some some suggestions, but I don't think she hasn't told me if any of them went through or anything. Um, but uh
Because I'm like, I can't be but like strani loves her alliteration. So I won't be surprised if like there's alliteration with some of the names
Just make names that are in new windows
Will you help them? No, I wanted to help. I did not help her with the names guys
I was hired and and assigned this model. I had nothing to do this conception of gen one
Um, I was literally just like a fan waiting like everybody else
And I applied and I didn't think I was gonna get it and I did hi here. I am
um
Watching your exposed. Yeah, that was funny
This is the slime that we hit though. Oh, you're just saying
That's so funny. She be manager for dentu. Um, I've already said like um after like a couple years
Or a few years like I would love to do some sort of like vtuber management
Um, again, that's very far away like guys. I'm not leaving. It's like a hundred years from now
I'm not leaving anytime soon and I'm taught and I would I would if like, let's say veeler blew up
And because I know strani only has a contingency for like
three gens if it blew up and she's just like
We're on gen like seven. I'm like, yeah, I'll be a manager
You know
Yeah, it's it's gonna be fun. Like I also like I love character building and stuff. So I'm very excited. Um
Cottonbomb kind of fire
I'm not leaving you stop crying. I'm not
I'm not g-wording gen seven good for
I'm not leaving you
Guys, I would probably be like a like a v sensei from like v4 marae
This will be like I'd be a manager, but also a streamer
But again, that's like years and years and years. Yeah, like our hn exactly
First a piece hn we love her
Uh, guys, I have to give myself a place in chat. This should be giving me my manager
No males allowed. Huck toa
Oh, I need to adjust. I'm sitting very bad
No, not like no guys
It's funny I got you guys I ordered the uh, like the what was it like the the fauna
sapling crying emote for you guys. So
For the for herob, so I hope you guys like it
You're already 46 so can't be that far
Because stop no guys stop it. I can see it now
All the all the news stuff
I was speaking of which uh
I told I told uh, you guys that I'm working on a project where I do I report because again, I was a commentator a report on news
um, I want to focus again
And this will be a project like in a couple months from now
Because I have to get a lot of stuff done
But I want to focus on like positive stuff and honestly just like saying what's going on
Like I know that might not sound interesting because I know like draw myself
But I'm like I I don't get a lot of information about like
And strontis helping me on a lot of stuff
I don't get a lot of information about like small corpo stuff
So because like uh, some some places don't really cover that anymore
So I want to like focus on like cool wins for small corpos and like individual stuff
Um, I don't want to be like drama-y like trust me. I was a commentator. I was drama-y before I know what that's like
I don't want I literally just want to be like this person like chio chompy
Just hit 10k subs from pixel link. Everyone congratulator right freaking now. Thank you. And that's the news. Good night. Like
um
I just like I want to uplift the community because I saw like what there is
A couple of tweets going around that people are like, oh my god, b2 being so negative and I'm like
I want to change that like I want to report on the good stuff
Like I want to report on the fun stuff like oh the vsmp server has this event. They just picked their candidates for
Something I don't know
About how it works. Um, but you guys know what I'm talking about. I don't know why I can't think of the word
I'm sorry the presidency. That's not how that works or like the mario card
Like I would want to report on those things like those those are fun
Those are awesome. Those are great community small corpo community events
Again, it would just be a focus on like small small corpo small corpo news
um
But yeah, happy news drama news
Yeah, more positivity because like I know I like I don't know about you guys
But like I loved watching the news with my mom and then they would talk about like a cat that like rescued like a kid or something
Like some like or like a dog that like got a medal and I'm like, yeah, let's do that
Let's focus on the good stuff instead of the bad stuff, you know
um
There's some channels like that. Yeah, exactly and because I have a bigger platform being an hdvtuber myself
I think that will help
uh
Because again, I might be like I'm not like huge but like I'm not like, um
Like I have like veeler offers me a branding and a presence so people would still like want to check stuff out just because
Um, but yeah spreading cheeks and spreading love
I I'm gonna have mercy sing the jingle and you like I need to get her to get on that
Because she came up with the thing
I hope I pinned it because she came up with like a a little jingle and I'm like, oh my god. I need to have mercy sing this
um
That's the goal. Yeah, like acapella magazine was great. Like you do you guys do a great job over there
It was awesome being interviewed from you guys. Um v sucky news network
Uh
No, I have a different name for it. I have a very like family friendly name for it because I'm it's going to literally be super family friendly
um
That'd be cool things trying. Yeah
news content. Yeah, no like I know
I again
I used to work for drama alert. I've said this before at least like I know what to do
I know what to look for. I know how to report news
So, yeah, she's about to kind of jingle
I figure how she said it
But she's saying she just like really made up something on the spot and it was adorable
I'm like, actually I might have to have you sing that for real and get it like
mixed and whatever
Family friendly with the shibs. Exactly. Holy shib folks. I like I'll just say stuff like that
Today in the news in the vtuber community. We have
Insert agency corpo here
In the publication you get
Yeah, yeah, exactly like people forget how wholesome we can be
Neanna commits another murder
lfi investigating
Sadly it won't be uh indie related
It'll be small just to keep like my sanity in terms of not like indie is bad, but because there's so many indie
Vtubers, I think I just want to focus on one side and I'm not going to do like larger and see like
I'm not going to do like haul live or needy stuff. Um
I want a little just do small corpo stuff, you know
um
There's tons and tons
No, I don't hate indies. I was literally an indie relax
Jingle the magic school bus opening with dealers
I
Need to buy a news anchor mustache. Oh
That's pretty good idea. I could just stop just like anchorman or something. Um
Yeah
Oh, yes play wedding witch very fun, although I didn't finish what I was doing
Because I just fell I'm literally probably gonna leave this open and just play it when I wake up tomorrow
Just finish the set the
Finish the level
Anchorman was great
Talk a lot if I use liver like liver celebrity gossip a bit far from oh my god
I said I was telling manager. I'm like I need an animation of me like running around trying to interview like inanimate objects or something
That's a microphone. Like I need like some ridiculous animation. He's just like
No, I'm like god damn it
I
Just feel you're gonna get another flip. No, she'll get flipped. Um
When I bring her because I'll see I I moved now that she's like eating normally and doing a lot better
I'm now sleeping in my bed and not outside because I slept near the couch
So I could bring her to the bathroom and like have access to everything a lot faster
and um
So this time like I've been bringing her to the bedroom and I made like a little like
Area for her on my bed that she can sleep and stretch out on
And so I'll I'll flip her for then. I have to flip my baby like a pancake. Um, if you're new here my cat fia as you can see
Uh, she's hanging out. Um, she is, uh
temporarily disabled
Such a weird way to say that but she has a rare autoimmune disease that makes her body shut down in terms of like moving around and stuff
But don't worry. She's on meds and she's doing a lot better and she can um move a little bit
But she can't stand or walk or hold her stuff up
But she's doing fine. Have a good night. Bye
Keep your hand out of frame if you want a green gloves to keep. Well, no, like my hands are fine
It's just like I know I'm gonna knock over the camera. That's what I'm scared of
Um, let's see. I've been up for a little bit. I'm slipping away very very fast. So let me let me raid somebody
You know, make them all dragon dogs. My dog dragon, but yeah, you guys know what I'm saying. That's so cool
Pay of the month is subscription fee your cat was purchased. That's terrible
That's terrible
If booby can be my field reporter and legal expert
Here's booby with the sports
Meow
Thanks booby back to you
Let's see
Uh
You know, it looks like dia fortuna
Started an hour ago question mark hour and a half
Hour ago. So I think it's safe to raid her
So
We'll do that we're trying our best. I'm trying so hard to raid properly
So you can she's doing a zatsu as well so you guys can go hang out with her. Um
She's blue
What
Please we're gonna pass in the bar exam safest raid. Okay, cool
But I hope you guys enjoyed your time with me. Um, thank you for sticking around if you're part of the raids and stuff
I appreciate you so much. Um, but yeah, I wanted as I said before like I want to do better
I don't want to make you guys sad or upset. Um, so I'm gonna be better at communicating and you know
Spreading joy and positivity
Yeah
Care about you guys a lot
I hope you guys enjoyed stream
Hope you enjoyed summer wean. This is summer wean. This is summer wean suck my wean suck my wean summer wean summer wean
I'm gonna go pass out. I can feel one of my cats bumping me
I think it's boomy is by my feet again. Like what are you doing? Go to bed
All right, bye everybody, where's my oh my god, it's like died hiccups
Um, but have a good night
sleep
Dream dream dream and this won't the ending screen is not purple. I'm so sorry
I'm a failure
I'm gonna keep the bgm off
This is medium working flashbang. What do you mean?
Anyways, good night y'all stay stinky
Oh my god, you're gonna make me sneeze with your stinkiness
Bye have a good night
Love you. Bye. Thank you for being amazing continue to do so
It won't be hard for you though because you're awesome. Bye